GOOD AFTERNOON WE'RE WAITING FOR
A COUPLE MEMBERS TO COME DOWN SO
WE CAN START AT LEAST AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
SO IF YOU'RE LISTENING -- IN
YOUR BOSS IS LOST TELL THEM TO
COME DOWN TO ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX
I BELIEVE IS RIGHT
.
AGAIN WE'RE WAITING FOR A COUPLE
MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLY EDUCATION.
WE REALLY NEED A MEMBER OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY HERE SO WE CAN
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
SYSTEM WORKING NOW [inaudible]
IT IS
[inaudible]
REMEMBER [inaudible]
A FIVE WE DON'T
-- OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON WE'RE GONNA START IS
SUBCOMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD HERE -- GOOD AFTERNOON.
I AM CALLING THIS HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
ORDER AS A SUBCOMMITTEE ONLY AT
THIS TIME.
BECAUSE WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM -- SO HOLD ON CALLING THE
ROLL -- WE HAVE EIGHT BILLS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY INCLUDING THREE
ON CONSENT.
THE MEASURES ON CONSENT ARE AS
FOLLOWS SB ONE SEVENTY FOUR SB.
FIVE EIGHTY TWO AND SB -- STR.
EIGHT WITH THAT -- WE ARE READY
HAVE OUR FIRST AUTHOR.
IT IS SENATOR PORTANTINO IT IS.
WE'LL TAKE A BILL NUMBER --
THREE TWENTY FIVE FIRST I GUESS --
TWENTY EIGHT THREE TWENTY EIGHT
IN ITS FINAL ORDER TO I BELIEVE
I LOVE.
PLAN NUMBER.
TWO WHEN YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY -- CENTER YOU'RE RIGHT
THERE GOOD THANK YOU CAN I WELL
THAT'S FINE.
WE'LL TAKE UP -- FILE.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT FIRST I'M
SORRY IT WILL TAKE UP TO TWENTY
ABSOLUTELY I'M SORRY I CAN'T I
CANNOT HEAR YOU.
NO I WAS GONNA ASK YOU TO THE
OTHER ONE FIRST BUT I'LL DO YOU
WANT TO DO.
YOU CHOOSE DON'T BOTHER ME.
I LET'S DO -- LET'S JUST GO
RIGHT.
TO THREE TWENTY EIGHT THERE WERE
THREE OF SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO THAT THAT GO.
SO LET US FIRST ESTABLISH A
QUORUM IF WE MAY SENATOR -- A
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL PRESENT O'DONNELL HERE
KILEY KILEY HERE.
DEEP.
KALRA MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH HERE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER HERE.
WE DO HAVE A CORE CORE HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY WE'RE GONNA GO WITH SB
THREE TWENTY EIGHT FIRST I
BELIEVE.
A MAYBE YOU MAY PERCY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
SB.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT TODAY ON
SCHOOL START TIME.
TEENAGERS IN OUR COUNTRY FRANKLY
ARE SLEEP DEPRIVED.
IT'S A PUBLIC HEALTH SEPARATE
EPIDEMIC AND ACCORDING TO
CONCLUSIVE MEDICAL RESEARCH.
THE PRIMARY CAUSE OF THE
EPIDEMIC IS EARLY SCHOOL START
TIMES THAT ARE NOT ALIGNED WITH
THE BIOLOGICAL SLEEP NEEDS OF
ADOLESCENT CHILDREN -- SB THREE
TWENTY EIGHT WILL UPDATE THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION CODE.
WITH A PUBLIC HEALTH PARAMETERS
FOR MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL START
TIMES.
THE REGULAR SCHOOL DAYS BEGAN AT
EIGHT THIRTY AM OR LATER FOR
HIGH SCHOOLS.
AND EIGHT AM OR LATER FOR MIDDLE
SCHOOLS THAT IS A DIFFERENCE
FROM LAST YEAR'S A BILL AND WE
THINK IT'S ACTUALLY A VERY GOOD
AMENDMENT.
FROM LAST YEAR AND MAKES THE
BILL -- BETTER BECAUSE IT
RESPECTS THE SCIENCE BUT GIVES
LOCAL DISTRICTS FLEXIBILITY
BETWEEN THEIR MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND
THEIR HIGH SCHOOLS AND THAT WAS
A SUGGESTION THAT CAME UP AND WE
THOUGHT IT WAS PRUDENT SO WE
INCORPORATED INTO THE BILL --
THIS COMES FROM A RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION
AND MANY HELL OTHER HEALTH AND
MEDICAL ORGANIZATIONS.
DESPITE DECADES OF OVERWHELMING
AND COMPELLING EVIDENCE OF THE
HARM TO TEENS FROM EARLY WAKE UP
TIMES.
THE VAST MAJORITIES OF
CALIFORNIA SECONDARY SCHOOLS
ABOUT 80% STILL BEGIN BEFORE
EIGHT THIRTY AM.
SO THAT THEY PREVENT MOST TEENS
FROM GETTING. TO THE GETTING THE
DOCTOR RECOMMENDED -- SLEEP FOR
GROWING BODIES AND BRAINS.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC THE AVERAGE
SECONDARY SCHOOL START TIME IN
CALIFORNIA IS.
EIGHT OH SEVEN AND MANY START
FIRST PERIOD -- WELL BEFORE.
SEVEN THIRTY EARLY SECONDARY
SCHOOL START TIMES FRANKLY HARM
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND SAFETY IN
MANY WAYS.
INSUFFICIENCY LEAP AMONG
ADOLESCENTS CAUSES HIGHER RATES
OF DEPRESSION ANXIETY SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS ACTIONS BEHAVIOR
PROBLEMS OBESITY DIABETES.
DROWSY DRIVING A CAR ACCIDENT
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND SPORTS
INJURIES.
THESE EARLY SCHOOL HOURS ARE
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS TO THE
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO CAUSE
OF DEATH AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE LET
pTHESE EARLY SCHOOL HOURS ARE
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS TO THE
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO CAUSES
OF DEATH AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE.
ARE ACCIDENTS AND SUICIDE.
I DON'T WANT TO READ.
ABOUT ANYMORE TEENAGERS -- WHO
HAVE TRIED FOR OF SUCCEEDED IN
TAKING THEIR OWN LIFE I JUST
DON'T WANT TO READ THAT ANYMORE?
AND WE BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL
HELP.
STEM THOSE -- SUICIDE --
THOUGHTS AND OCCURRENCES.
THE STATUS QUO ALSO CAUSES WORSE
ACADEMIC OUTCOMES RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT SLEEP DEPRIVATION AMONG
ADOLESCENTS STUDENTS.
BECAUSE A SLEEPING IN CLASS
DIFFICULTY PAYING ATTENTION
FORGETFULNESS MORE ABSENCES MORE
TARDY'S MORE DISCIPLINARY ACTION --
WORSE GRADES AND TEST SCORES AND
HIGHER DROPOUT RATES.
AND THE STATUS QUO IS ACTUALLY
WIDENING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
AND HEALTH DISPARITIES IN OUR
STATE BECAUSE EARLY STARTS ARE
PROVEN TO HER DISADVANTAGED
CHILDREN.
THE MOST MANY STUDIES SHOW THAT
DISADVANTAGED CHILDREN ALREADY
GET LESS SLEEP THAN THEIR MORE
PRIVILEGE PEERS AND THEY FACE
MORE OBSTACLES GETTING. TO EARLY
BELLS ON TIME AND ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THE HARM OF DEVELOPMENTALLY
INAPPROPRIATE START TIMES.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT ACCORDING
TO THE CDC LATER START TIME
SEARCH THE SINGLE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTION.
WITH THE POTENTIAL TO HELP THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF CHILDREN TO
COMBAT THE ADOLESCENT SLEEP LOSS
EPIDEMIC.
THERE'S EXPANSIVE AS EVIDENCE
SPANNING DECADES THAT WHEN
SCHOOL STARTLING SKIT MORE SLEEP.
THEY'RE HEALTHIER HAPPIER LESS
LIKELY TO CONTEMPLATE SUICIDE
LESS LIKELY TO GET IN THE CAR
ACCIDENTS THERE TENANTS GOES UP
THE GRADES GO UP.
AND GRADUATION RATES GO UP AND
IN CALIFORNIA INCREASED
ATTENDANCE MEANS INCREASED
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE FUNDS
TO SCHOOLS -- AND AS IF THAT
WEREN'T ENOUGH THE RAND
CORPORATION PROJECTS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY WILL GROW
BY ABOUT ONE BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR OVER THE NEXT.
DECADE AS A RESULT OF HIGHER
GRADUATION RATES FEWER CAR
ACCIDENTS WOULD LATER START AND
OTHER COMPLICATIONS FROM OUR
CURRENT EARLY START TIMES.
AND EVERY YEAR THE EVIDENCE JUST
KEEPS AMOUNTING.
A RECENT STUDY OF THE SEATTLE
PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICTS A LARGE
URBAN DISTRICT WHICH ADOPTED
LATER START TIMES.
CONFIRMED THE PREVIOUS FINDINGS
WITH THE SHIFT A LATER START
STUDENTS ARE GETTING MORE SLEEP
GETTING BETTER GRADES AND
ATTENDING SCHOOL MORE OFTEN.
ATTENDANCE IMPROVE THE MOST THAT
SCHOOLS WITH THE MOST LOW INCOME
STUDENTS COMEY SAID AGAIN
TENANTS IMPROVED AT THE SCHOOLS
WITH THE MOST LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
STUDENT ATHLETES ARE BIG
BENEFICIARIES OF HEALTHY SCHOOL
START TIMES AS WELL ACCORDING TO
RESEARCH WELL RESTED STUDENT
ATHLETES PERFORM BETTERIN THEIR
SPORT.
AND GET INJURED LESS OFTEN.
WE KNOW THAT HEALTHY SCHOOL
HOURS.
HOURS THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF WELL
RUN SCHOOL DISTRICTS A CUT
ACROSS THE NATION THAT THRIVE
WITH LATER AGE APPROPRIATE START
TIMES.
AT THEIR MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOLS
THEY HAVE HEALTHIER AND SAFER
STUDENTS AND SUCCESSFUL SPORTS
PROGRAM THE DATA AND EVIDENCE IS
COMPELLING.
EARLY MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
START TIMES CLOSE A PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY RISKS TO OUR
STATE YOU.
AND FRANKLY I JUST THINK IT'S
TIME DID YOU PUT THAT DATA AND
THE RESEARCH AND THE RESULTS TO
USE AND HELP THESE KIDS.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FREQUENTLY SETS HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS FOR OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM. FOR EXAMPLE
ONE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE REVEALED
THE DANGERS OF ASBESTOS LEAD
PAINT SMOKING -- IMMUNIZATION --
THE LEGISLATURE ACTED TO PROTECT
KIDS.
SO TO THE LEGISLATURE CAN AND
SHOULD ACT IN ACCORDANCE WITH
ITS AUTHORITY AND RESPONSIBILITY
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S SIX
MILLION PUBLIC SCHOOL CHILDREN.
FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH RISK SO.
OBVIOUSLY WHEN APPROPRIATE I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE WITH ME TODAY I HAVE DR
RAFAEL PALLADIO FROM STANFORD
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
I HAVE JOY WAKE FROM START
SCHOOL LATER AND I HAVE DR ANOOP
CURRY POT A CHILD PSYCHIATRIST
WITH SCRIPTS HEALTH AND
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
SLEEP SOCIETY. TO MAKE OUR CASE
SO I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK THEM
TO HAVE THE TIME TO MAKE THEIR
CASE.
I YOUR FIRST WITNESS I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE SIX MINUTES SO I YOU
MAY HAVE CUT IT UP ANY ANYWHERE
YOU DESIRE SO THERE YOU'RE.
NOT USED AT ALL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY I'M A PROFESSOR
AND PHYSICIAN I STANFORD
UNIVERSITY. TOO MANY HOUSEHOLDS
BEGIN THE DAY WITH A STRUGGLE TO
GET THEIR TEENS OUT OF BED.
AND IT ENDED A WITHIN ARGUED
ABOUT GOING TO SLEEP.
SB THREE TWENTY ACRES PARENTS
AND STUDENTS MORE CONTROL OVER
THEIR HEALTH.
THE EVIDENCEIS CLEAR AND
OVERWHELMING THERE ARE LESSONS
ARE SUFFERING FROM HARMFUL
CHRONIC SLEEP DEPRIVATION.
EARLY SCHOOL START TIMES ARE
PROVING TO BE MODIFIABLE
CONTRIBUTOR TO THEIR SLEEP
DEPRIVATION.
SCIENCE TEACHES US THAT OUR
LESSONS ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO SLEEP DEPRIVATION
BECAUSE THERE'S A BIOLOGICAL
SHIFT IN THEIR BRAINS RHYTHMS.
MOST TEENS CAN'T JUST GO TO
SLEEP EARLIER.
THE AMERICAN CARRY PEDIATRICS
HAS DETERMINED THAT EARLY SCHOOL
START TIMES PREVENTS MOST TEENS
FROM GETTING HEALTHY SLEEP THEY
NEED.
A SCIENTIFIC REVIEW OF NEARLY
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND TEENAGERS
HAS FOUND THAT TO SLEEP DURATION
IS AN INDEPENDENT RISK FACTOR.
FOR DEVELOPMENT OF SUICIDALITY.
THE LOWEST RISK IS FOR STEVE
DURATIONS OF EIGHT TO NINE HOURS.
MOST TEENAGERS ARE LUCKY TO EVEN
GET SEVEN HOURS ON SCHOOL NIGHTS.
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATIONS OF PUSH
SCHOOLS TO START TOO EARLY.
THIS HAS LED TO PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS INCLUDING
INCREASED CAR ACCIDENTS.
ALL OF YOU PROBABLY KNOW
TEENAGERS ON ANTI DEPRESSANTS
SLEEPER RESTORED TO BRING IN
HEELS THE MIND.
THESE KIDS BRAINS ARE STILL
DEVELOPING.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT RESEARCH
HAS CONSISTENTLY SHOWN THAT
DELAYING TO SCHOOL START TIME IS
IMPROVE THE WELL BEING OF
TEENAGERS.
THE BIOLOGY OF THE STEEP CANNOT
CONTINUE BE TREATED AS AN
INCONVENIENCE.
THIS STATE IS NOT BEING ASKED A
SET SCHEDULE FOR INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICTS.
THE STATE ASSEMBLY BEING ASKED
TO ESTABLISH A FLOOR AND HOW
EARLY SCHOOLS CAN FORCE
TEENAGERS TO BE IN CLASS.
LET THERE BE NO DOUBT THE WEIGHT
OF THE EVIDENCE IS SO COMPELLING
THE PROFESSIONAL HELP SOCIETIES
ARE CALLING FOR ACTION.
THE AMERICAN OKAY PEDIATRICS
STANFORD CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF SLEEP
MEDICINE THE NATIONAL SLEEP
FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA ZIP
SOCIETY AMONG SEVERAL OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AGREED AT THIS BILL IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
THERE ARE ZERO HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS OPPOSING THIS BILL.
NOT A SINGLE.
ONE NOW YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TRANSLATE THE SCIENCES THE
SOUND PUBLIC HEALTH POLICY AND
SEND THE MESSAGE THAT WE VALUE
HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN OF ALL OF
THE CONCERNS.
PLEASE GIVE THESE GUYS A BREAK
AND LET THEM SLEEP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EVEN FOR KIDS WITH
GOOD SLEEP HABITS EARLY SCHOOL
START TIMES MANDATE THAT MOST
TEENS WAKE UP AT TIMES THAT
DOCTORS SAY INCREASE THE RISK
FOR MANY ILLNESSES SUICIDE AND
ACCIDENTS.
I'M SURE WE WOULD ALL LIKE TO
THINK THAT CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND
SAFETY IS THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY IN OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
BUT IN THIS CASE AT SOME
DISTRICTS IT ISN'T PRIORITIZED.
THOSE IN THE SYSTEM WITH A STAKE
IN THE STATUS QUO HAVE TOLD YOU
ALL OF THE MANY ADMINISTRATIVE
OBJECTIVES THAT THEY VALUE MORE
THAN THE HEALTHY SCHOOL START
TIMES FOR TEENS.
THAT'S WHY OUR CHILDREN NEED SB.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT CURRENTLY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN DISREGARD
THIS HEALTH AND MEDICAL POLICY
GUIDELINES AND CONTINUE TO HARM
THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF TEENS WITH
DEVELOPMENTALLY INAPPROPRIATE
SCHOOL HOURS.
THE STATE WIDE POLICY IS THE
REMEDY.
AND IT'S NECESSARY BECAUSE
ADOLESCENT SLEEP DEPRIVATION IS
A PUBLIC HEALTH EPIDEMIC WHOSE
PRIMARY MODIFIABLE BECAUSE IS
THIS PUBLIC EDUCATION POLICY.
BECAUSE PUBERTY BECAUSE AFTER
YOU READY KIDS NATURALLY STAY
AWAKE LATER.
EARLY SCHOOL START TIMES DEPRIVE
MOST TEENS OF THE STATE THAT
THEY'RE GOING BODIES AND BRAINS
NEED.
OUR CHILDREN SLEEP HEALTH HAS
FALLEN THROUGH A RESPONSIBILITY
GAP.
DEFAULTING THIS IMPORTANT
STATEWIDE PUBLIC HEALTH MATTER
TO OVER FIVE HUNDRED INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOL BOARDS HAS PROVEN
DETRIMENTAL TO CHILDREN.
AFFECTING CHANGE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL HAS PROVEN VERY DIFFICULT
BECAUSE ALL OF THE STRUCTURAL
BARRIERS THAT EXIST THERE. FOR
EXAMPLE MANY SCHOOL BOARDS DON'T
ACTUALLY HAVE THE FINAL SAY ON
WHAT TIMES ARE SCHOOL START
BECAUSE OF CONTRACT LANGUAGE
WITH BARGAINING GROUPS WE
SUPPORT COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
BUT NOT FOR OUR KIDS HEALTH IS
JUST TOO IMPORTANT.
AND ALTHOUGH ELLIE GAYS ARE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR A LOT THEY ARE
NOT ACCOUNTABLE FOR INCREASING
TEEN SLEEP OR DECREASING DROWSY
DRIVING ACCIDENTS ETCETERA.
SO THE MANY EDUCATIONAL
OBJECTIVES OVER WHICH SCHOOL
BOARDS ARE ACCOUNTABLE GET
PRIORITIZED.
BUT THE LEGISLATURE ON THE OTHER
HAND ALL OF YOU CLEARLY HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY AND THE AUTHORITY
TO PROTECT OUR STATE'S CHILDREN
FROM KNOWN PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY RISKS THE AD CODE IS
FILLED WITH SUCH PROTECTIONS.
AND BESIDES GIRLS ARE HARM TO
MORE THAN BOYS FROM THE STATUS
QUO.
GIRLS ARE HARMED MORE BECAUSE
THEY GO THEY GO THROUGH PUBERTY
CERNER AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
GIRLS ARE SPECIALLY HARM BECAUSE
THEY GO PURITY GO THROUGH
PUBERTY CENTER THAN WHITE GIRLS.
WE BELIEVE EVERY CHILD DESERVES
EQUAL PROTECTION FROM KNOWN
PUBLIC HEALTH RISKS AND NO CHILD
SHOULD HAVE THEIR HEALTH
DETERMINED BY THEIR ZIP CODE
INCOME LEVEL OUR RACE.
WE TRULY UNDERSTAND THAT HEALTHY
SCHOOL START TIMES WILL TAKE
SOME EFFORT AND IN SOME CASES
RESOURCES.
BUT THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
SIX MILLION CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
ARE WORTH THE EFFORT.
MANY DISTRICTS NATIONWIDE HAD
ALREADY PROVEN THAT YOU DON'T
NEED TO HARM TEENS HEALTH AND
SAFETY TO EFFICIENTLY ADMINISTER
SCHOOL DISTRICT A TRANSPORTATION
DEPARTMENT OR HAVE A THRIVING
EXTRACURRICULAR PROGRAM.
AS ADULTS IT IS OUR MORAL
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT CHILDREN.
AND AS ADULT LEADERS YOU HAVE
THE POWER TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR THANK YOU. FOR YOUR SPEAK
ABOUT A MINUTE SIR GOD YES THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY I AM A
PRACTICING PHYSICIAN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I'M A BOARD CERTIFIED
PSYCHIATRIST I TYLER JOHNSON
PSYCHIATRISTS IN THE PEDIATRIC
SLEEP MEDICINE SPECIALIST.
I'M ACTUALLY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF TYLER
DOZEN PSYCHIATRISTS THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
SCHEDULES I DO WHAT I'M THE
PRESIDENT.
I HAVE.
PRACTICE MEDICINE I'VE SEEN MY
FIRSTHAND THE EFFECTS OF
DECREASED SLEEP AND UNDER THE
FOR SLEEP ON MENTAL HEALTH ALL
OF THESE -- AS CHILDREN WITH THE
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL
I'VE SEEN THEM SOUTH OF WITH
INCREASED ANXIETY ON BREAKING UP
INCREASED DEPRESSION OFTEN
HAVING IN ATTENTION FOCUSED
ISSUES AND OFTEN GOING AND
SLEEPING IN CLASS HAVING POOR
SELF ESTEEM.
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO
COPE WITH THE PRESSURES THEY
OFTEN GET BIG PLEASE SOMEONE OF
SLEEP THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IN
THIS FILM ARE DECREASED AND WANT
OF SLEEP THAT THEY GET.
THE MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH
SCHOOL KIDS HAVE TREMENDOUS
STRESS ON TOP OF IT HAVING
BECAUSE SOMEONE ASLEEP OFTEN
MAKES THEM.
WONDERFUL TO HAVE MOMENTOUS
DISHES.
I DO THINK THAT SUMMER AYE SIR
NO AMOUNT OF SLEEP EDUCATION
WHICH WE CAN FOR A WIDE CAN HELP
THEM IF THE STATE STILL MANDATE
THEM TO WAKE UP EARLY.
AND EARLY THANK THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT -- AND OTHERS IN
SUPPORT MAY COME TO THE
MICROPHONE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY IT IS NOT TIME FOR
FURTHER COMMENT.
TOM NELSON.
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA PROUD SPONSOR OF SB.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT ALSO
CHAIRPERSON FOR THE PARENT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON EL CAP FOR
A LARGE DISTRICT REPRESENTING
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND PARENTS
AND STUDENTS PLEASE PROMOTE.
THE GENERAL WELFARE FOR IS A
KILLER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY THE NEIER OF REPRESENTING
STUDENTS ALL OVER SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT SENATE
THANK YOU.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT WE GET THE
DOOR CLOSED IN THE BACK.
BECAUSE WE CAN THAT LOW MY NAME
IS NOISE I'M SORRY JUST BECAUSE
THE NOISE COMES IN.
SO THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE KEY TO
NEIER AND BEHALF OF ALL HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS I SUPPORT BILL.
SEE I SPEAK.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT SIMON VIEW
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
BEHAVIOR HEALTH -- CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL COMMUNITY PAY FOR HEALTH
AGENCY AND WE SUPPORT ABOUT.
HELLO MY NAME IS CARTEL YAY ON
BEHALF OF ALL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT SB.
THREE THREE EIGHT HELLO I'M
HEALY PHILLIPS FROM RIO
AMERICANO AND I SUPPORT SB.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT HELLO MY NAME
IS JULIETT DEL CORE OF FOR ME
AMERICANA HIGH SCHOOL AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE RARE
AHMANSON I'M FROM MARYLAND HIGH
SCHOOL AND I SUPPORT SB.
THREE TWENTY DEBORAH OUGHTON
COUNSELOR PSYCHOTHERAPIST FOR
THIRTY NINE YEARS I ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HOW LAME THING TO MY
PEDIATRICIAN ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
IN STRONG SUPPORT?
LARA HOLLIS PARENT THANKS FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL.
HELLO LAURIE MORALIS PARENT OF
TO GRADUATES OF FROM THE SEMI
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
CHILE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HE BERMAN ROW.
PARENT OF GRADUATES FROM
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS.
I AM DEFINITELY SUPPORTING THE
STUDENTS AND THIS BILL.
HI MINUTIA BASHING CAT CAN ON
GOING TO DISINTEGRATE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SU CHILLING.
REGISTERED NURSE START SCHOOL
LATER.
I VERY MUCH SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SIMON CATKIN I'M
GOING TO NINTH GRADE I
SUPPORTERS BILL.
SCHEDULING PHYSICIAN WITH
BECAUSE PERMANENTLY FOR THIRTY
TWO YEARS I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
STEPHANIE FREDRICKSON PARENT OF
TWO TEENS ADD EL CAMINO -- HIGH
SCHOOL I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CHRIS TRAILER PASSED STYLE --
HIGH SCHOOL GUEST TEACHER
SUBSTITUTE TEACHER AND PASSED
PTA PRESIDENT I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
RENDON TO IT ON BEHALF OF ADVICE
AND SUPPORT.
MCEWAN PARENT OF TWO CHILDREN
FROM SAN JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT PASSED ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL PTA PRESIDENT.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KOBE PRESIDING A ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AS A WASHINGTON UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT -- TRUSTEE IN
SUPPORT THANK.
I'M SHANNON SELLABAND
PEDIATRICIAN A MOTHER OF A
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD PUBLIC SCHOOL.
STUDENTS A RESIDENT OF MEMO PARK
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GEN MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MEGAN ALL RIGHT
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
MATT ROBINSON KAISER PERMANENTE
SHANNON PRIMER SPECIAL NEEDS
PARALEGAL I'M I'M ALSO FROM
EDUCATE ADVOCATE EMPOWER FAMILY --
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I'M AND DEL CORE I'M ON THE
PARENT AND SUPERINTENDENT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE IN THE SAN
JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS LIKE SO TO RALLY I'M
A STUDENT AT REMARK ON A HIGH
SCHOOL AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
BEAR CENTER ON BEHALF OF THE
PASADENA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
BOARD OF EDUCATION SUPPORT.
HELLO I'M IN A CAR I AM A PARENT
OF TWO TEENAGERS.
THERE IN THE SAN JUAN UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI PEGGY PARKER I'M WITH THIRD
DISTRICT PTA MEMBERSHIP V. P. WE
COVER THE EIGHT COUNTIES AND I'M
ALSO A GRANDPARENT OF TWO
TEENAGERS SO I DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY WILL HAVE THE
OPPOSITION COME UP [inaudible]
M. PRESENT.
THE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
JUST COME FORWARD AND YOU MAY
SIT AT THE TABLE HERE.
NUMBER TWO I THOUGHT THEY WERE.
TOO I'M NOT SURE IF YOU CAN YEAH --
MORE THE MERRIER.
AND THEN BAD.
PROBLEMATIC OKAY.
CAN I BECAUSE I THINK.
REFER ME TO ME YEAH.
YEAH BE READY.
YES PROCEED WITH X. MINUTES
TOTAL MY NAME IS IAN CAMPBELL
PHD -- APPROACHING LOUDER.
MY NAME IS IAN CAMPBELL PHD I'M
A PROJECT SCIENTISTS AT THE UC
DAVIS SLEEP LAB.
AND THAT ONE IT SAY THE THE
VIEWS THAT I'M EXPRESSING TODAY
OR FROM MY MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS IN RESEARCH AND SLEEP ON
AND MORE THAN THAT OR NINETEEN
OR SO ON ADOLESCENT SLEEP AS A
SIGN TO THE UC DAVIS AND THEY
ARE MY OWN.
AND NOT NECESSARILY THOSE
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA HOPE YOU HAD
A CHANCE TO READ THE LETTER THAT
IRWIN FIND BURKE AND I WROTE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL ARE
BRIEFLY REVIEW OUR REASONS FOR
OPPOSING IT.
MANY ADOLESCENTS TO DO HAVE A
CIRCADIAN PHASE DELAY THAT
CAUSES THEM TO PREFER A LATER
BEDTIME HOWEVER SLEEP SCIENTISTS
DO NOT FULLY UNDERSTAND THIS
PHASE DELAY.
RATHER THAN THAT THE DELAY
RESULTING FROM CHANGES IN BRAIN
CIRCUITS THAT RGULATE CIRCADIAN
RHYTHMS THE BEST EVIDENCE IS THE
ADOLESCENT SLEEP NEED
ACCUMULATES MORE SLOWLY ACROSS
THE DAY AND THIS ALLOWS THEM TO
STAY UP LATER.
A RECENT MODELING STUDY
DEMONSTRATED THAT RATHER THAN
ACCOMMODATING THE PHASE DELAY BY
ALTERING SCHOOL START TIME A
MORE EFFECTIVE APPROACH IS TO
REDUCE EVENING LIGHT EXPOSURE.
FURTHERMORE SLEEP RESEARCHERS DO
NOT FULLY UNDERSTAND HOW SLEEP
NEED CHANGES DURING ADOLESCENCE
OUR LAB IS CURRENTLY CONDUCTING
AN NIH FUNDED STUDY TO ADDRESS
THIS QUESTION.
SECOND PROPONENTS FAILED TO IN A
KNOWLEDGE OF THE EVIDENCE THAT
THE INITIAL SLEEP IN THE INITIAL
INCREASE IN SLEEP DURATION
FOLLOWING SCHOOL START TIMES MAY
NOT PERSIST.
IT IS REASONABLE TO ASK IF WE
DELAY START TIMES WANT TEENS
JUST STAY UP LATER.
A LONGITUDINAL STUDY FOUND JUST
THAT DELAYING PARTS HIGH SCHOOL
START TIME FROM SEVEN FORTY FIVE
EIGHT THIRTY AM.
PRODUCED AN INITIAL TWENTY
MINUTE INCREASE IN SCHOOL AND
SLEEP DURATION DUE TO A TWENTY
MINUTE LATER RISE TIME.
HOWEVER SIX MONTHS LATER
BEDTIMES WERE ALSO DELAYED
TWENTY MINUTES RESULTING IN NO
CHANGE IN SLEEP DURATION.
THIRD A NATIONWIDE STUDY
ORIGINALLY CROSS SECTIONAL STUDY
SHOWED THAT EIGHT THIRTY MAY NOT
BE THE APPROPRIATE LIMIT AND
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT APPROPRIATE
FOR ALL ALL SITUATIONS.
THE ASSOCIATION BETWEEN START
TIME AND SLEEP DURATION.
WAS STRONGEST PRIOR TO EIGHT AM
AFTER EIGHT AM THERE WAS NO
RELATION BETWEEN STILL START
TIME AND SLEEP DURATION.
THE AUTHORS RECOMMENDED MORE
RESEARCH TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE EFFECTS OF SCHOOL START TIME
CHANGES WE AGREE.
INSTEAD OF COMPELLING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ADOPT THE STATE
MANDATED START TIME WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PERHAPS
ASSISTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE MANY SLEEP SCIENTISTS IN THE
STATE.
PROVIDE GUIDELINES SO THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WANT TO
DELAY START TIMES CAN COLLECT
APPROPRIATE DATA TO EVALUATE THE
POSITIVE AND NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF
THE CHANGE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CINDY GARDNER SCHOOL
BOARD PRESIDENT FOR ROOM OF THE
WORLD UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHICH IS IN THE MOUNTAINS OF
SAMBAR NAY DINO ENCOMPASSING
SCHOOL BOUNDARIES A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE SQUARE MILES.
IN THE ELEVATION FROM FORTY
SEVEN HUNDRED FEET TO SEVENTY
TWO HUNDRED FEET. 71% OF OUR
STUDENTS RELY ON HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION DUE TO OUR
WORKING FAMILIES OUR UNIQUE
GEOGRAPHICAL CHALLENGES IN THE
WEATHER CONDITIONS OF OUR
DISTRICT. TO IMPLEMENT A LATER
START TIME FOR HIGH SCHOOLS IN
THE CURRENT STAGGERED START TIME
SCHEDULE WE HAVE.
ROOM WOULD NEED TO DOUBLE ITS
FLEET OF BUSES AND STAFF FOR ONE
TIME COSTS A THREE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AN ONGOING COSTS
OF ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS.
WEARING DECLINING ENROLLMENTS SO
IN ORDER TO AVOID INSOLVENCY
THIS WOULD EQUATE TO THE LAYOFF
OF TWELVE TEACHERS INCLUDING THE
ENTIRE HIGH SCHOOL'S CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION DEPARTMENT.
LAY OFF AN ASSISTANT PRINCIPAL
FOR COUNSELORS FIVE LIBRARIANS
AND THREE SECRETARIES THERE
WOULD BE A REDUCTION OR
ELIMINATION OF ARE MOST.
HELPFUL PROGRAMS SUCH AS OUR
VIRTUAL AND CREDIT RECOVERY
PROGRAMS THAT HELP THE MOST AT
RISK STUDENTS GRADUATE.
THE ELIMINATION OF DRAMA BAND
FIELD TRIPS CHOIR AND MY
FAVORITE ATHLETICS WE WOULD ALSO
HAVE TO LIMóN EIGHT THE
TEXTBOOK ADOPTION FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS.
BECAUSE WE CANNOT TRUNCATE OUR
BUS TURN AROUND TIMES CREATING
OTHER STAGGERED START TIME
OPTIONS ALL HAD NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES.
STARTING ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS AT
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT AM HIGH
SCHOOL AT EIGHT THIRTY AM IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL AT TEN FIFTEEN AM
WOULD MAKE THE FIRST PICK UP AT
THE MOST REMOTE BUS STOPS.
AT SIX TWENTY TWO AM FOR THE
ELEMENTARY STUDENTS SO ARE
REALLY YOUNG TKA FOUR YEAR OLDS
ARE GOING TO BE STANDING AT BUS
STOPS DURING THE WINTER IN THE
DARK IN THIS NOW.
THE LAST MIDDLE SCHOOL STUDENT
BUS DROP WOULD BE FIVE FORTY ONE
PM.
AND MAY PRECLUDE PARTICIPATION
IN AFTER SCHOOL ACTIVITIES LIKE
KARATE DANCE LESSONS C<c.cyan> AND</c>
USE SPORTS.
MY DISTRICT HAS APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTY NINE POINT 5% OF OUR
STUDENTS RECEIVING FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE MEALS SO WHY
THOUGH GEOGRAPHY OF MY DISTRICT
IS UNIQUE OUR STUDENT POPULATION
LOOKS A LOT LIKE THOSE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET OUR SINGLE PARENTS AND OUR
LOW INCOME STUDENTS THEY JUST
CAN'T GET THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL
THAT LATE?
THEY JUST CAN'T SO WHAT I'M
ASKING YOU IS FOR THESE
UNINTENDED NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES.
AND OTHERS LIKE IT I WANT YOU TO
VOTE NO ONE SB. TWENTY NINE
THREE TWENTY EIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M GLAD THAT WOULD
WORK ON THE DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS AND
COMMUNITY RELATIONS AT THE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT.
I'M HERE TO TODAY TO EXPRESS THE
DISTRICTS OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL IMPACT ON AC
TRANSIT OPERATING BUDGET.
AND PREVENT THE DISTRICT FROM
PROVIDING THE CURRENT LEVEL OF
SUPPLEMENTAL SCHOOL SERVICE THAT
WE DO TODAY.
EASY TRANSIT PROVIDES A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY NINE THOUSAND TRIPS A
DAY INCLUDING ABOUT THIRTY
THOUSAND DAILY STUDENT TRIPS.
AT TRANSIT COORDINATES WITH EACH
SCHOOL TO STAGGER START TIMES TO
ALLOW MULTIPLE SCHOOLS TO BE
SERVED BY A SINGLE BUS AN
OPERATOR.
THIS COURT NATION ENABLES US TO
PROVIDE THE MOST EFFICIENT LEVEL
OF SERVICEAND ALLOWS THESE
BUSES TO TRANSITION TO COMMUTER
SERVICE AFTER THE SCHOOL
SERVICES COMPLETE.
IF THE SCHOOL START TIMES CHANGE
THERE WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN DEMAND FOR MORNING
SERVICE BECAUSE A LATER START
TIME WILL CONFLICT WITH THE
MORNING COMMUTE.
AC TRANSIT SCHEDULES FORTY SIX
BUSES EACH MORNING COULD TO
ACCOMMODATE SCHOOL SERVICE IF SB
THREE TWENTY IS ENACTED THE LOSS
OF STAGGERED START TIMES AND THE
INCREASED DEMAND WILL REQUIRE AC
TRANSIT. TO SCHEDULE A TOTAL OF
SEVENTY THREE BUSES IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THE SAME LEVEL LET'S
SAME LEVEL OF SERVICE THIS
REPRESENTS A 60% INCREASE IN
OPERATING COSTS FOR US.
WITHOUT ADDRESSING THE COST
IMPACT OF HOW STUDENTS GET TO
AND FROM SCHOOL AND HOME AC
TRANSIT WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO TO
MAINTAIN THE CURRENT
SUPPLEMENTAL SERVICE THAT WE
PROVIDE.
THEREFORE ON BEHALF OF AC
TRANSIT I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON
SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY PLEASE.
NICOLAS CHAVEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS WHO ARE
LINE ARE COMMON TO THE PREVIOUS
TWO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
KEVIN FROM HALF THE COMPTON A
FIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICT IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
SEC BRAMBLE HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE COULD SUPPORT A
PILOT BUT WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL.
STEVE ALL COMBAT THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION'S ALSO OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL.
THERE CLINICS ON BEHALF OF THE
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION AND DECEMBER LEADING
UP COUNTY DISTRICT ADVOCATES FOR
BETTER SCHOOLS IN OPPOSITION.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSE.
JEFF BOCK ON BEHALF OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN OPPOSITION.
HAVING A CRIED REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ARE ALSO OPPOSED.
HILLARY HALL SIXTH GRADE TEACHER
REPRESENTING THE NEW HOLES
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE.
ESTHER CAM SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER OF THE NORTH SCHOOL
DISTRICT ALSO OPPOSE.
ANDREA BALL IN THE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
THE ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION PROPOSED.
BARBARA DAWSON MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER INVESTOR I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
DIRECTORY A SOCIAL SCIENCE
TEACHERS WHO ARE IN HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT I OPPOSE.
CALLING BURNER SCHMIDT -- FORTY
FOUR YEAR EDUCATOR FROM GRADES
K. I. T. K. THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL --
I OPPOSE THIS.
MISC APPEAR ST ELK GROVE
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MARGIE WERE NOT A KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER MONEY BILLION FIVE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSE.
I BULLARD DIED UP PRESIDENT
CONTINUE EDUCATION ASSOCIATION I
OPPOSE.
DOUG PETS CASKEY TEACHER AT
MONTEBELLO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND PRESIDENT OF THE
MONEY BILL TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
I OPPOSE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRIS
BOUCHER I'M A CHEMISTRY TEACHER
BEVERLY HILLS HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
BEVERLY HILLS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I OPPOSE SB.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT I'M JAMIE
OSMAN I'M AN ENGLISH TEACHER
JUNIOR HIGH ENGLISH TEACHER IN
THE HEART SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IN SANTA CLARITA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR SIXTH GRADE
TEACHER AND PRESIDENT OF THE
INGLEWOOD TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TIFFANY TERO TWENTY NINE YEAR
HIGH SCHOOL ENGLISH TEACHER AND
PRESIDENT OF THE ST LAWRENCE
VALLEY TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SERGIO MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION CTA BOARD
OF DIRECTOR TEACHER OF THIRTY
SEVEN YEARS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVEN WAY YES I'M
FROM SAN MEDINA COUNTY TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE LOCAL IN MY
PRESENCE I'M THE PRESIDENT OF MY
LOCAL SKEWS ME.
I'M ALSO AN EARLY CHILDHOOD
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
KATHY PIERRE SAMUEL COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOLS IN A
SPECIAL EDUCATION EARLY START
TEACHER AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GET AFTERNOON NUMBER AND A WALK
OR I'M PRESIDENT OF ASSOCIATED
CHINO TEACHERS IN SALMON ID
DON'T COUNTY I'M ALSO A SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER AND WE OPPOSE
THE SPELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SUSAN
SCALA AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
TO LIVE IS TO EDUCATORS -- IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY SIXTH GRADE
TEACHER AND OUR ASSOCIATION
OPPOSES THIS BILL THANK YOU.
BOB BLATTNER FOR THE OAK GROVE
UNIFIED IRVINE UNIFIED NEWPORT
MESA UNIFIED AND WEST COVINA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
STRONG OPPOSITIONS FOR THE
REASONS SO ELOQUENTLY STATED
THANK YOU. TWO WE WALKER
NATIONAL BOARD CERTIFIED TEACHER
MIDDLE SCHOOL SCIENCE TEACHER
AND PRESIDENT OF THE SWEET WATER
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION.
AND WHAT I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE COLD WAR -- FOURTH FIFTH
GRADE TEACHER HERE IN SACRAMENTO
SEXY UNIFIED. TWENTY YEARS -- I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK
BEHIND THE DíAS -- ALL KIND OF
START OFF HERE WITH SOME OF MY
THOUGHTS -- IN MY MIND A
PRACTICAL I'M I'M A PARENT OF
TWO TEENAGERS.
BUT A TEACHER FOR A LOT OF YEARS.
AND YOU KNOW.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT YOU KNOW
WE'VE HEARD OF THE NANNY STATE
I'M FEARFUL THAT THIS IS THE
STAVING THE NANNY.
RIGHT -- IN A AND I THINK THIS
MIGHT BE GOOD POLICY.
AT THE DISTRICT LEVEL BUT MY
CONCERN IS A SETTING THAT I MEAN.
YES SETTING.
THE THE SCHOOL BELL FROM
SACRAMENTO AYE I JUST DON'T
THINK WE KNOW EACH DISTRICTS.
NEW ONCE IS ENOUGH TO SAY WELL
WE KNOW BEST AND THIS IS WHAT IT
SHOULD BE.
ACROSS OUR STATE BUT AGAIN I'M
NOT OPPOSED TO TO STARTING
SCHOOL LATER AT ALL.
NOT AT ALL BUT I JUST THINK IT'S
IT'S GOOD LOCAL POLICY.
BUT NOT NECESSARILY GOOD STATE
POLICY TO DESIGNATE THE START
TIME FOR EACH SCHOOL DAY
COMMISSION WE SHOULD BE SENATE
AND TIME AND TIME TO GET TO KNOW
A LOT OF QUESTIONS YOU RESET THE
SCHOOL KELLER.
I WISH SCHOOL STARTED AFTER
LABOR DAY HOW MANY OF YOU WISH
THAT WOULD HAPPEN RIGHT BUT I'M
NOT GOING TO SPONSOR A LAW. TO
DO THAT BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS
THE PURVIEW OF A LOCALLY THAT'S
RIGHT NEXT YEAR ELECTED ELECTED
WHERE.
EXACTLY -- RELEASE BOILS DOWN TO
ME -- IT TOGETHER TAKE TO ME
THIS WAS ON A SURFBOARD A COW
AND A TRAIN.
OKAY A SURF BOARD WISE I'VE
SHARED BEFORE MY DAUGHTERS IN
THE SURF TEAM AT OUR LOCAL HIGH
SCHOOL.
IN TWO DAYS A WEEK HER FIRST
PERIOD IS ACTUALLY AT SIX FORTY
FIVE IN THE MORNING RIGHT SHE
OPTS INTO THIS.
AND SHE IS TO BE DOWN IN THE
WATER.
RIGHT AND SO FIRST HEARD HER
FIRST PERIOD IS ACTUALLY SIX
FORTY FIVE IN THE MORNING COUPLE
DAYS A WEEK.
AND SO SHE DOESN'T GO TO FIRST
PERIOD AT SCHOOL AND AND THIS
WOULD.
YOU KNOW KILL THAT PROGRAM
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
HAPPEN BEFORE SCHOOL THAT NOT
EVERYBODY'S AWARE OF AND AGAIN
SHE OPTS INTO THIS PROGRAM IS
NOT MANDATORY THAT SHE'S ON THE
SURF TEAM.
BUT I AM VERY PLEASED THAT SHE
IS I THINK IT BROUGHT SCHOOL
SPIRIT BILL SCHOOL COMMUNITY
WHEN KIDS ARE ENGAGE IN SPORTS
BEFORE OR AFTER SCHOOL -- SOME
SCHOOLS HAVE AGRICULTURAL
PROGRAMS OR CERTAIN PROGRAMS
THAT THEY DO UNIQUE THING THINGS
THE MORNING I'M A CITY BOY.
BUT FROM WHAT I KNOW YOU DON'T
KNOW COUNT THREE IN THE
AFTERNOON.
RIGHT YOU HAVE TO DO IT IN THE
EARLY MORNING HOURS AND THIS
AGAIN WOULD.
POTENTIALLY HARM SOME OF OUR AG
PROGRAMS AROUND THE STATE -- IN
A TRAIN THERE'S A SCHOOL IN
ORANGE COUNTY THAT I'M AWARE OF
THAT THEY HAVE TO SET.
THE SCHOOL DAY ACCORDING TO WHEN
A TRAIN GOES BY BECAUSE SO MANY
CARS GET BACKED UP BY THIS TRAIN.
SO AGAIN THERE'S JUST SO MANY
NUANCES ACROSS OUR STATE AND
HOUSE WAS OPERATING WHY THEY
OPERATE ON THE TIME TABLE THEY
DO THAT I DON'T THINK.
IT'S GOOD TO TO TO TO GET SET
THAT THAT THAT START TIME FROM
SACRAMENTO I'M A MOMENT A LOCAL
CONTROL GUY I THINK A LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD HAS THE EXPERTISE
TO DO THIS.
WE'RE STATE THAT'S DIVERSE IN
PEOPLE YES BUT ALSO GEOGRAPHY
AND THAT MEANS A LOT OF THINGS --
I MEAN WHY HAVE A SCHOOL BOARD
AGAIN IT'S A QUESTION I ASK
WORKING FAMILIES.
RIGHT THIS IS GOING TO IMPACT
THEM.
AND I COME FROM A DISTRICT WHERE
THERE WAS A LOT OF WORKING
FAMILIES AND I KNOW THIS IS
GOING TO FALL ON OKAY.
TYPICALLY IS GONNA FALL ON THE
WOMAN.
OKAY MY WIFE AT HOME WITH THE
KIDS RIGHT NOW I'M UP HERE RIGHT
SHE SAYS HAVING A GOOD TIME.
RIGHT BUT IT THIS BURDEN IS
GOING TO FALL ON WORKING WOMEN.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE MORE HEAVILY
THAN OTHERS.
I WAS GONNA COST CHILDCARE
ISSUES.
PEOPLE HAVE TO GO TO WORK I
DON'T THINK.
BUSINESS IS GONNA NOT OPEN
BECAUSE THE SCHOOL DAY OR
THEY'RE GOING TO CHANGE THEIR
START TIME BECAUSE THE SCHOOL
DAY.
START TIME AT HAS STARTED --
IT'S GONNA COST MORE MONEY AS
IT'S BEEN OUTLINED FOR BUSES
BECAUSE THERE'S ONLY A CERTAIN
WONDER YOU GOT TO GET KIDS TO
SCHOOL RIGHT.
YOU DON'T WANT THEM GOING TO
SCHOOL AT TEN THIRTY BECAUSE I
JUST GONNA DRIVE IN LATER INTO
THE AFTERNOON WITH THE EARLY
EVENING HOURS WILL BE AT SCHOOL
SLEEP I THINK THE THE DOCTOR'S
POINTED OUT THAT.
THEN WHEN I HEARD AND SAY THE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT YEAH KIDS
MIGHT HAVE SLEPT TWENTY MINUTES
MORE THAN.
ALL OF SUDDEN THEY THEY WENT
ABOUT TWENTY MINUTES LATER RIGHT
SO I I DON'T KNOW THAT THIS IS
NECESSARILY GOING. TO LEAD TO
MORE -- SLEEP BACK TO THE BUSING
ISSUE WE WE HAVE KIDS OUT THERE
ON A BUS IN THE DARK.
RIGHT BECAUSE OF SOME OF THESE
RURAL COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY
WORK IN FACT WE HAVE SOME REAL
COMMITTEES I THINK STILL HAVE A
FORTY SCHOOL TO AWAIT.
RIGHT SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR
THEM BECAUSE THEY ONLY HAVE A
CERTAIN WINDOW TO TO TRANSPORT
KIDS IN THOSE THOSE ARE THOSE
ARE SIGNIFICANT SAFETY ISSUES A
KID SITTING OUT THAT.
A CHILD SITTING OUT IN THE SNOW
IN THE DARK I DON'T THINK THAT'S
THAT THAT'S A HEALTHY SITUATION
THE BLOCK SCHEDULE THAT HASN'T
BEEN BROUGHT UP.
BUT I KNOW WITH MY DAUGHTER I
THINK SHE'S TO BE A SCHOOL LIKE
SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN FIFTY FIVE A
COUPLE DAYS A WEEK AND EVERY DAY
SHE GOES AT NINE THIRTY SO THIS
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT THE
BLOCK SCHEDULE THAT THE BLOCK
SCHEDULE OFFICE OFFERS KIDS.
STUDENTS AND SCHOOLS INTO AN
ADVANTAGE IN THE ALSO KIDS WHO
CREDIT RECOVERY MAKE UP THE BOX
IT WAS GREAT FOR THEM BECAUSE
THEY CAN ACTUALLY TAKE X.
RECURRENCE.
SO MY FEARS OF THIS WAS THIS
WOULD ADVERSELY IMPACT.
THE THE BLOCK SCHEDULE I HAVE
ANOTHER CONCERN.
OR OR THOUGHT MAYBE WE SHOULD
JUST GONNA WRITE A BILL THAT HAS
PARENTS PUT THEIR KIDS TO BED.
NINE AND A HALF HOURS BEFORE THE
STE.
IN THE SCHOOL STARTS WRITING IS
REALLY KIND OF AN ISSUE THE
BOILS DOWN.
TO OUR PARENTS.
YOU KNOW INTERACT WITH OUR
CHILDREN SO SO SO THAT'S AN
ISSUE THERE IS ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT'S COME UP AND IT'S AN
UNKNOWN.
AND I DON'T THINK WE'RE GONNA
HAVE AN ANSWER. TO IT RIGHT NOW.
WOULD IT HAS TO DO WITH EIGHTY A
MINUTES YOU'VE GOT IT SAYS --
WITH AN UNKNOWN HERE'S THE BILL --
AUTHORIZES JUSTER STRONGER
CLASSES TO A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE'S BEFORE.
BEFORE THE START OF THE SCHOOL
DAY -- THAT DO NOT GENERATE ADA
SO THE THE QUESTION IS HOW DOES
THAT INTERACTS.
WITH THE SCHOOLS ABILITY TO
GENERATE EIGHTY EIGHT WILL THEY
HAVE ENOUGH MINUTES AT THE END
OF THE YEAR TO GENERATE ADEQUATE
ADA SO MAY.
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON AT
AND I DON'T THINK WE HAVE THE
ANSWER TO THAT THAT'S GOOD I
CAME UP TODAY AND IT'S GONNA
TAKE.
I DON'T THINK THAT YOUR INTENT
I'M SURE OF THAT WITH THAT THAT
IS A QUESTION AND AGAIN I WHERE
I COME FROM IS.
AGAIN GOOD POLICY POR LAW.
THAT'S JUST SIMPLY WORST AND I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY ELSE HAS
ANY COMMENTS.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISS SHERRIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR THOUGHTS WHICH CAN IN
YOUR EXPERIENCE AND OUR
HEARTFELT MEANINGFUL A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
ONE I UNDERSTAND THIS AS EXAM TO
RULE SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- WHICH
WHICH I KNOW HAVE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES.
THAT -- SOME OF THE URBAN
DISTRICTS MAY NOT.
BE ENGAGED AND AND THEN TO THIS
LAST POINT OF OR THE WHO OPENED
THE CHAIR TALKING ABOUT.
YOU HAVING A SERVING CLASSIC
EARLY IN THE MORNING AND WHAT
THAT MEANS IN TERMS OF I THINK
IT'S ITEM FOR THAT SIMPLY SOME
THE ANALYSIS AND AND LOOKING
YOUR BILL THERE IS A AN EGG AN
EXEMPTION OR AT LEAST -- THAT TO
ALLOW FOR A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IS TO BE GAUGES CERTAIN
ACTIVITIES SO -- THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING I DON'T KNOW THAT
REQUIRES MORE CLARIFICATION AS
THIS MOVES FORWARD TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT THE KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES THAT -- THE CHAIR THE
CHAIR O'DONNELL IS REFERRING TO
WOULD STILL BE ALLOWED FOR YEAH
IF I COULD RESPOND. ZERO APPEARS
EXAM I MEAN THAT THAT'S THAT'S
THE WHOLE POINT -- IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT -- THE PTA WAS
ADAMANT -- IN EXPRESSING BEFORE
THEY CAME ON BOARD I AGREE WITH
THAT.
THOSE OPTIONAL OPT IN.
PROGRAM THEIR EXAMS YOU KNOW --
THAT'S THAT'S JUST WHAT THE LAW
DOES YOU KNOW IF IT NEEDS MORE
CLARITY WILL BRING MORE BUT WE
THINK THAT'S PRETTY CLEAR -- AND
I'M HAPPY TO TO TRY TO TIGHTEN
THE LANGUAGE BUT YOUR CORRECT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE ZERO PERIOD
IS EXEMPT -- AN INTERESTING BY
PRODUCT WHAT SOME SCHOOLS
ACTUALLY SEE -- IS THAT
ATTENDANCE AT ZERO PERIOD -- TO
POSIT A BY PRODUCT THAT MORE
KIDS WILL OPT INTO THE
ENRICHMENT PROGRAMS.
AS ZERO PERIOD MOVES SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU HAVE A CURRENT
SCHOOL THAT STARTS AT SEVEN
THIRTY YOUR APPEARANCE AT SIX
THIRTY A LOT OF KIDS WON'T.
OPT INTO A SIX THIRTIES YOU'RE
PRETTY PARTICULAR WE SEEN BOYS
MUSIC PROGRAMS WHEN THAT SCHOOL
MOVES TO EIGHT THIRTY AND ZERO
APPEARED GOES.
TO SEVEN THIRTY WE SEEN THE
NUMBER OF BOYS IN THOSE
ENRICHMENT PROGRAMS OFTEN AGAIN
THAT'S VOLUNTARY.
BUT THAT'S A POSITIVE BY PRODUCT
OF THAT BUT YOUR PEERS ARE
EXEMPT.
AND COMES UP EVERY TIME WE BRING
IT UP IN THE ANSWERS BUT YEAH SO
THAT JUSTICE ONE THAT
CLARIFICATION AND I KNOW THERE'S
A THERE'S A A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT STUDIES AND AND
THEY'RE STILL -- MAYBE SOME
LIMIT TO THE NUMBER OF DISTRICTS
THAT THAT HAVE IMPLEMENTED --
DELAYED SCHOOL START -- EITHER
IN THIS STATE OR ANOTHER STATE
SENATE ACTUALLY DONE STUDIES ON
IT AND SO -- IF THIS BILL WERE
TO MOVE FORWARD IF IT EVER GOT
ENACTED INTO LAW I THINK THAT'LL
BE IMPORTANT TO GET SOME OF THE
REPORT BACKS THE STUDIES AS THE
REAL IMPACTS BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S TWO THERE'S TWO VERY
LEGITIMATE -- OPPOSING OPINIONS --
BUT I ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE THE
THE THE THE SCIENCE AND AND I
KNOW ONE OF THE STUDY SHOWS THAT
THOUGH THE ONE IS REFERRED TO IN
THE REPORT IN THE ANALYSIS --
ACTUALLY ANNOUNCED BY THE STAFF
BY THE WAY -- THAT IN SEATTLE
THE LITTER SCHOOL TIMES.
LED -- TO INCREASING PUNCTUALITY
AND TEN IS A PERFECTLY AMOUNTS
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED.
SCHOOLS I'M SO I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S A NUMBER OF X. FACTORS I
THINK THAT MOVING IT.
YOUR DOCTOR GONNA HAVE SOME
PARENTS GONNA BECAUSE OF AN
ISSUE WITH SOME PARENTS MIGHT
MAKE IT EASIER -- FOR BUT I DO
THINK THAT THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT.
ONCE YOU'RE ACCUSTOMED TO A
CERTAIN SCHEDULE THAT YOURS YOUR
SCHEDULE GETS ADJUSTED SO
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT IT IT
WOULD CERTAINLY TAKE.
SOME EFFORT OF FOR EVERYONE TO
TO HAVE TO READJUST AND I KNOW
THAT.
COSTS -- PARTICULARLY BECOMES
TRANSPORTATION IS SUCH ARE
SOMETHING THAT -- WE ALL HAVE TO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT -- SURE -- I
WOULD HAVE TO YOU KNOW THE
DECISION TO COME TO US -- AT
SOME POINT IF THERE'S A IF THERE
IS A REAL ISSUE WHEN IT COMES TO
COST AND TRANSPORTATION WITH
SOME OF THE DISTANCE I DO HAVE.
A MORE EXTENSIVE BUSING AND IN
PARTICULAR -- BUT BUT I I THINK
THAT -- THE BUT WITH ME IS A
SIGN IS THE SCIENCE AND AS THE
CHAIR INDICATED GOOD POLICY --
GOOD POLICY ISN'T ALWAYS EASY TO
IMPLEMENT AND SOMETIMES IT'S NOT
EVEN SUPPOSED TO BE EASY TO
IMPLEMENT.
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
DON'T PURSUE IT -- AND SO WITH
THAT I'M I MAKE THEM OUT OF MY
COMMISSION WITH THE BILL
[inaudible]
ANYBODY ELSE.
SOME REMEMBER SPENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
PERSONALLY WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR MOST SINCERELY FOR
HIS DILIGENCE IN THIS EFFORT I
WAS FOLLOWING THIS BEFORE I WAS
A MEMBER OF THIS BODY.
AND I KNOW THAT HE APPROACHES
THIS BECAUSE OF HIS COMMITMENT
TO OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH.
AND REGRETTABLY I CAN'T BE THERE
WITH YOU TODAY WITH AN
AFFIRMATIVE VOTE I AM GOING TO
ABSTAIN -- BUT I WILL SAY THIS%
TO OUR COALITION OF EDUCATION
FOLKS IN THE ROOM.
THE EVIDENCE IS STARTING TO
BECOME INCREASINGLY COMPELLING.
AND WE ARE OBLIGATED AS A STATE
WITH A SIGNIFICANT MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS TO START LOOKING AT HOW
WE STOP THIS WITH OUR YOUTH.
AND I CANNOT CONTINUE TO TALK TO
DISTRICT AFTER DISTRICT TO SAYS
WE NEED MORE COUNSELLING SUPPORT
WE NEED A PSYCHOLOGIST ON STAFF
ABSOLUTELY OF COURSE YOU DO.
BUT IF THERE IS SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN DO LIKE THIS THAT WE CAN
FIGURE OUT THE LOGISTICS OF THAT
WE CAN FUND OF THE LOGISTICS OF
TO HELP GIVE OUR STUDENTS ONE
MORE MEASURE OF SUCCESS AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE THAT
BALANCE IN MENTAL HEALTH WE
OUGHT TO DO IT AND SO MY
COMMITMENT IS TO THIS AUTHORS IF
WE DON'T GET THIS OUT TODAY AND
I HATE TO NOT BE A PART OF THAT
BUT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
THE CONVERSATION BECAUSE
SOMETIMES WE COMPEL GOOD.
POLICY CHANGE BY FORCE AND
SOMETIMES WE COMPILE IT BY AN
OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF EVIDENCE
THAT SAYS IT IS NOW THE RIGHT
THING TO DO AND IN THAT FIGHT
AND I AM WITH YOU.
THANK YOU IF GO AHEAD DOCTOR
WEBER YES I I DO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR -- HE'S BEEN VERY
PERSISTENT AND WITH REGARDS TO
THIS BILL AND AND OBVIOUSLY IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO HIM.
AN IMPORTANT TO TO ALL OF US WHO
I THINK YOU'RE ABOUT KIDS -- YOU
KNOW MY MY CONTACT WITH THIS IF
INFORMATION GOES WAY BACK TO
WHEN I WAS ON THE SCHOOL BOARD
WHICH IS SOME TWENTY SOME ODD
YEARS AGO -- WHERE THE RESEARCH
BEGAN AND AND PEOPLE BEGIN TO
TALK ABOUT THE NEED FOR CHANGE
AND IT'S NOT AN EASY THING I
THINK THE THE MOST DIFFICULT
TIME EVER HAD ON SCHOOL BOY WAS
SIMPLY CHANGING TIMES?
WHEN SCHOOL STARTS AND STOPS?
FOUR HOURS WAS FOR BUSING
REASONS MUCH MORE THAN ACADEMIC
REASONS AND IT ALWAYS SEEMS LIKE
IT'S GOING TO CREATE THE END OF
THE WORLD FOR PEOPLE TO CHANGE
FROM TWENTY MINUTES TO THIRTY
MINUTES.
WHATEVER IT MAY BE AND AND YET
AND YOU TAKE THAT HARD DECISION
YOU MAKE WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO AND
AND INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH THEN
PEOPLE GO ON WITH THEIR LIVES.
THEY MAKE THE ADJUSTMENT THEY
MOVE ON A EVEN FORGET WHAT THAT
THE STARTING TIME USED TO BE
BECAUSE NOW THEY'RE ON A
DIFFERENT TIME AND AFTER.
WE ADJUST THEIR LIVES TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN -- THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
BUT I THINK THAT THE THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING ABOUT THIS IS
THAT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT WHAT
IS GOOD FOR KIDS.
AND WHAT THE HELPS THEM -- TO
BASICALLY IT JUST WELL AND TO DO
WELL IN SCHOOL AND WE SHOULD BE
SEEKING EVERY.
METHOD THAT WE CAN FIND TO MAKE
THE WORLD BETTER FOR OUR KIDS.
WE SEEM TO BE IN AN AVALANCHE OF
PROBLEMS IN TERMS OF THE KIDS
HAVING ISSUES AND DEPRESSION AND
SUICIDE.
ALL KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE JUST
FEEL OVERWHELMED BY AT AND AND
WELL THIS IS NOT A SILVER BULLET
IT HAS SOME EVIDENCE THAT SAYS
THIS CAN BE DONE.
AND IT CAN BE DONE TO THE
BENEFIT OF OUR CHILDREN.
AND I KNOW EVERY DISTRICT WANTS
TO DECIDE IT'S ONLY ISSUES.
I'VE HAD A LOT OF THESE
DISTRICTS WHO ASKED ME THAT WE
DO THIS SO THEY THEY DON'T HAVE
TO FIGHT THE BATTLE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND DEAL WITH ALL THE
PARENTS TO COME IN THE SCREAMING
AND THE HOLLERING AND THEN
THEY'RE SUBJECT TO ELECTION AND
THEY DON'T.
KNOW OVERWHELMED BY IT -- BUT
YOU KNOW I'VE LISTEN TO THIS THE
STORIES FOR A VERY LONG TIME
ABOUT WHY WE SHOULDN'T DO IT AND
AND ALL THE THINGS THAT.
THAT YOU GIVE PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE IN CHARGE OF
AND TO TAKE AND AND WHAT WE
BELIEVE IN LOCAL CONTROL OF THE
REALITY IS WE DO A LOT OF THINGS
THAT ARE NOT LOCAL CONTROL AND
WITH ITS TERMS OF CURRICULUM AND
ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
WE REALIZE.
HAVE TO BE DONE AT THIS LEVEL
THAT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
OUR KIDS SO THIS IS A DIFFICULT.
DECISION -- BUT IT'S ONE THAT I
THINK IS IS WORTH DOING.
AND EVEN ONE OF OUR MEMBERS
TALKED ABOUT LAST TIME WAS ON
THE FLOOR AND THIS IS PROBABLY
THE CHEAPEST THING WE CAN DO TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF OUR KIDS.
EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW IT'S GOING
TO TAKE MONEY FOR BUSING IN
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS BUT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE OUTCOME IT'S
WORTH WHATEVER THE EXPENSES THAT
WE SAVE ONE LIFE.
IT IS TRULY WORTH IT IF WE CAN
TRANSFORM MANY OF THE SCHOOLS TO
HIGHER PERFORMING SCHOOLS -- IT
IS TRULY WORTH IT BECAUSE WE
HAVE TRIED SO MUCH AND WE HAVE
PUT SO MUCH MONEY INTO SO MANY
OTHER THINGS THAT HAVE NOT
WORKED.
AND AND IT BRINGS WEEK MAKES ME
QUITE SAD YOU KNOW I WAS AT A
SCHOOL.
OF THIS WEEKEND AT A AT A SWIM
MEET FOR MY GRANDKIDS.
WHEN I JUST HAPPEN TO LOOK AT
THE DATA FOR THE SCHOOL BECAUSE
I WAS GOING TO SCHOOL NEED TO
FIND WHERE IT WAS AND?
AND WAS IN A COMMUNITY -- AND IT
MACAM COMMUNIS MAJORITY WHITE
BUT IT'S SUPPORT COMMUNITY AND I
WAS I WAS REALLY QUITE UPSET
WHEN I GOT THERE TO THIS AND AND
I LOOK AT THE DATA THAT OVER
HALF OF THE KIDS DROP OUT OF
SCHOOL.
OVER HALF OF THE KIDS IN THIS
DISTRICT DROP OUT OF SCHOOL.
AND THEY'RE IN THE 30% OFF AND
ON AND ON AND ON AND WENT ON AND
ON AND AND I WAS JUST LIKE MY
GOODNESS WHAT IS GOING ON HERE
WHY ISN'T THERE.
A BILL BEING WRONG WHY ISN'T
THERE SOME ALARM OCCURRING.
AND AND I KNOW THAT IN THIS ONE
COMMUNITY THERE'S A LOT OF
DRINKING THERE'S A LOT OF OF CAR
ACCIDENTS THAT HAPPEN IS A LOT
OF TRAUMA AND STRESS.
AND IN THE END ONE OF THE EAST
COUNTY SCHOOLS IN SENEGAL COUNTY
AND IT'S NOT IN MY DISTRICT BUT
I JUST HAPPEN TO LOOK AT THE
DATA OF WHAT I SAW AND I SAW A
LOT OF TRAGEDY.
AND A LOT OF PAIN IN THIS
DISTRICT JUST LOOKING AT THE
INFORMATION OF AND I THOUGHT TO
MYSELF AND I'VE GOT TO TALK TO
MY COLLEAGUE WHO'S THAT THE
SCHOOLS A MEMBER THERE.
WHY HAVEN'T YOU SET A SET THE
ALARM WHY HAVEN'T YOU RAISE THIS
ISSUE I MEAN IT'S INCOME IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE IN THIS IN THIS DAY
AND AGE TO HAVE OVER 50% OF YOUR
KIDS NOT GRADUATED FROM HIGH
SCHOOL?
AND AND SO I THINK THERE'S JUST
SO MANY THINGS GOING ON IN SO
MUCH PAIN IS SO MUCH DIFFICULTY
IN FAMILIES AND ALL KINDS OF
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO A LITTLE
BIT OF SOMETHING. TO MAKE IT A
LITTLE BIT BETTER -- AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE DONE --
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED IS IS WORKING
ON BASICALLY DOING THEIR
DISTRICT AND IN THIS WAY BECAUSE
THEY REALIZE THAT WE'VE GOT TO
DO A BETTER JOB.
IT WILL BE TO BEEN DOING AND IF
THIS CAN HELP.
ALLEVIATE THE PROBLEM SOLVE SOME
OF IT WE CAN'T SO I WANNA THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR COMING TODAY.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS AGAIN
BECAUSE I'VE COME UP LIKE I SAID
I'VE KNOWN THIS FOR OVER TWENTY
SOME ODD YEARS AND HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO MOVE DISTRICTS IN THAT
DIRECTION -- BUT I THINK AT THE
STATE LEVEL IF WE CAN PROVIDE
THE DIRECTION IN THE SUPPORT
THAT'S NECESSARY THAT MAKES THE
TRANSFORMATION EASIER FOR
DISTRICTS WE HAVE TO DO THAT FOR
OUR KIDS OF NOTHING ELSE THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU A SINGLE OF MR KILEY
I'M SORRY.
THIS IS THAT I BELIEVE THE THIRD
TIME THIS BILLS COME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE -- AND ALTHOUGH SHE
SAID IT'S NOT THE SAME BILL --
IT -- THIS TIME AROUND -- EXAMS
RURAL DISTRICTS.
IT -- STAGGER START TIMES FOR
MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND HIGH SCHOOLS
WHICH IT DIDN'T DO BEFORE.
THE PROVIDES GREATER FLEXIBILITY
IN THE PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF THE
BILL ALTHOUGH IN MY VIEW STILL
NOT ENOUGH STILL NOT THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF FLEXIBILITY
AND STILL HAS SOME WAY TO GO IN
THAT RESPECT -- WHEN I'VE BEEN
WHEN I FAILED TO VOTE FOR THIS
BILL IN THE PAST?
IT'S BEEN.
A DIFFICULT DECISION BECAUSE THE
EVIDENCE I THINK IS QUITE
POWERFUL I THINK THAT THE WEIGHT
OF THE EVIDENCE ALTHOUGH
APPARENTLY THERE ARE SOME.
CONFLICTING STUDIES BUT THE
WEIGHT OF THE EVIDENCE SUGGESTS
THERE ARE BENEFITS ALONG.
SEVERAL DIMENSIONS -- TO OUR
KIDS WHEN WE START SCHOOL LATER
AND OUT FROM REDUCE TRAFFIC
ACCIDENTS.
TO GRAB INCREASE GRADUATION
RATES TO IMPROVED ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE -- AND TO WHAT
REALLY STRUCK ME WAS THAT MENTAL
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES THIS IS BEEN
A FOCUS OF OUR COMMITTEE WE
CONVENE AND ADD A INFORMATIONAL
HEARING EARLIER THIS YEAR.
REALLY FOCUSED ON THE VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE OF MENTAL HEALTH
IN OUR SCHOOLS THE CHAIR AND I
HAVE JOINTLY AUTHORED BILLS TO
TRY TO IMPROVE MENTAL HEALTH IN
OUR SCHOOLS AND THERE'S STILL A
LOT OF WORK TO DO BUT THE
EVIDENCE.
HERE IS VERY POWERFUL WHEN IT
COMES TO THE IMPACT ON YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH OVER SIXTY STUDIES
LINK SLEEP LOSS WITH SUICIDES
TEENAGER THE MOST SLEEP DEPRIVED
AGE GROUP THEY'RE DEVELOPING
BRAINS.
ARE ALSO THE MOST VULNERABLE TO
SUICIDAL THOUGHTS AND THE RISK
OF SUICIDE DECREASES BY ELEVEN
AT PERCENT.
WITH EACH ADDITIONAL HOUR OF
SLEEP.
SO WHAT HELD ME BACK FROM
SUPPORTING THE BILL IN THE PAST
IS THIS IDEA OF LOCAL CONTROL.
AT THESE DECISIONS ARE BEST MADE
BY IN AT THE LEVEL WHERE IT IS
CLOSEST TO THE FAMILIES THAT ARE
AFFECTED.
AND AND LOCAL CONTROL ALLOWS FOR
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO BE TRIED
AND SUCCESS TO BE REPLICATED THE
TRUTH IS WE DON'T.
ALLOW FOR NEARLY ENOUGH LOCAL
CONTROL IN THE STATE.
WE HAVE -- THIS FIRM IS INVOKED
SO SELECTIVELY.
OUR EDUCATION CODE IS WAY
THICKER THAN IT SHOULD BE
COMPARED TO OTHER STATE IS ONE
OF THE REASONS OUR EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES.
LACK.
AND IT'S TRUE THAT I'VE HAD OVER
THE COURSE OF THAT. THREE TIMES
I CONSIDER THIS BILL MANY SCHOOL
LEADERS DISTRICT LEADERS SCHOOL
WHERE MEMBERS REACH OUT AND SAY
THIS IS A MATTER FOR OUR
DISTRICT TO THE SIDE -- AFTER
RECEIVING INPUT FROM OUR
COMMUNITY.
BUT LIKE DOCTOR WEBER I'VE ALSO
HEARD.
FROM SCHOOL LEADERS AND DISTRICT
LEADERS.
WHO SAY THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE IN THIS DIRECTION BUT THERE
ARE SYSTEMIC BARRIERS TO DOING
SO -- THE SUPERINTENDENT OF ONE
OF THE DISTRICTS IN THE AREA I
REPRESENT -- MADE THE POINT THAT
IF THEY'RE JUST RECORDED CHANGED
AND THEY'D BE OUT OF SYNC WITH
THE NEIGHBORING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WHICH WOULD PRESENT A LOT OF
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF ENTRY
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES.
AND OTHER THINGS AND THERE'S
EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
THIS IDEAS WELL THERE'S AN
ARTICLE HERE FROM THE JOURNAL OF
EDUCATION -- AND HEALTH WOOD
SAYS THE BECAUSE OF LOCAL WISE
CONTROL NEIGHBORING SCHOOLS ARE
NOT ANSWERABLE TO EACH OTHER AND
REGIONAL ATTEMPTS AT CHANGE CAN
BE THWARTED BY ONE SCHOOL BOARD.
LOCAL CONTROL HAS BECOME IN THIS
INSTANCE THE REASON THAT SCHOOL
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS HAVE LIMITED
CONTROL OVER THEIR ABILITY TO
ACT ON THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE NATION'S PEDIATRICIANS.
LOCAL CONTROL BECOMES LOCAL LACK
OF CONTROL.
THIS PARADOX AND OF COURSE THE
OVERWHELMING SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
IS WHY MANY EXPERTS ARE CALLING
FOR THE STATE'S TO STEP IN THE
STATE HEALTHY BOUNDARIES. FOR
SCHOOL START TIMES.
SO.
BECAUSE OF THIS COLLECTIVE
ACTION PROBLEM I THINK THE LOCAL
CONTROL ARGUMENT AT LEAST CUTS
BOTH WAYS.
AT THAT POINT I THINK IT'S ONLY
FAIR TO DEFER TO THE OVERALL IN
WYOMING WEIGHT OF SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE AS FAR AS WHAT IS IN
THE INTEREST.
OF OUR KIDS -- NOW THAT BEING
SAID I AS I SAID BEFORE I STILL
DON'T THINK THERE IS ENOUGH
FLEXIBILITY.
IN THE BILL SO I JUST WANT TO
ASK THE AUTHOR I WOULD YOU
COMMIT AND FOR WHAT IT IS ONE
EXAMPLE WITH DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
A ULTIPLE CONFIGURATIONS OF
RATE LEVELS.
THIS CAN PRESENT UNIQUE
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF
TRANSPORTATION OTHER THINGS SO I
WHAT WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO
COMMIT TO WORKING TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES TO ARRIVE
AT THE RIGHT LEVEL OF
FLEXIBILITY BEFORE -- THIS BILL
GOES INTO EFFECT SO FIRST OF ALL
OF THE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ANALYSIS -- THE COMMENT YOU MADE
ARE ARE VERY VERY HELPFUL
CONVERSATION AND I APPRECIATE
YOU'VE DELVING SO DEEP INTO IT.
BECAUSE YOU HAD THE HEART OF THE
AP HEADED OUT OF THE PARK.
THE REASON WHY THIS BILL HAS A
THREE YEAR IMPLEMENTATION CYCLE
I MEAN I RECOGNIZE THAT IF WE
SAID TODAY OR JANUARY ONE WHEN
THIS BE BECOME LAW.
YOU HAVE TO CHANGE YOUR BILL
SCHEDULE [inaudible]
THAT FALL.
WE KNOW THAT'S TOO MUCH TO ASK
THE REASON WHY THIS BILL HAS A
THREE YEAR IMPLEMENTATION CYCLE.
IS PRECISELY TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS YOU BROUGHT UP IS
TO WORK WITH THE DISTRICTS.
YOU KNOW THIS WILL FRANKLY FORCE
DISTRICTS THE PLAN FOR THE
CHANGE WHICH WILL IDENTIFY IT'S
MY INTENT.
DURING THAT THREE YEARS I HAVE
FIVE AND A HALF YEARS LEFT HERE.
TO WORK WITH THE DISTRICTS IN
CONCERT AND IN COLLABORATION TO
ADDRESS THOSE THINGS FOR EXAMPLE.
ONE LEGITIMATE ISSUE THAT'S COME
UP THERE'S A HANDFUL OF SCHOOLS
OUT THERE THAT DON'T HAVE LIGHTS.
ON THEIR SPORTS FIELDS THAT'S A
LEGITIMATE.
ISSUE YOU KNOW I'M GOING TO WORK
ON A FUNDING SOURCE TO TRY TO
HELP THOSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
DON'T HAVE LIGHTS DURING THAT SO
YES I WOULD TOTALLY COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH YOU.
AND THE CHAIR AND MISS SMITH YOU
KNOW I THINK YOUR POINTS WERE
WERE WELL TAKEN -- TO THAT'S THE
WHOLE POINT.
WE HAVE THREE YEARS TO WORK ON
IT IN CONCERT BUT IF EVERYBODY
SAYING NO.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT SIT DOWN CONVERSATION.
THAT GIVES THAT THE ROBUST --
FOCUS WE NEED SO YES OBVIOUSLY
I'M GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THOSE ISSUES.
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DEDICATION TO THIS ISSUE AND I'M
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY.-THANK YOU.
I SEE NO FURTHER COMMENT -- YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU -- AND TAKE
THE CHAIR YOU KNOW.
I I KNOW THAT.
WHEN THERE'S A CHANGE THIS
DRAMATIC?
YOU KNOW IT'S HARD -- YOU HAVE
EXPERTS IN THE CLASSROOM YOU
HAVE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS WHO
HAVE STRUGGLE WITH THESE ISSUES --
THE COMMENTS YOU'VE ALL MADE OUR
OUR JERMAINE AND AND THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS TO ASK WHAT IS THE
IMPACT ON WORKING FAMILIES WELL.
THAT'S THE RIGHT QUESTION.
THE DATA SHOWS THAT UNDER THE
CURRENT SYSTEM THERE'S A SOCIAL
INEQUITY IN WORKING CHILDREN
WORKING FAMILY HOUSEHOLDS ARE
THE MOST DISADVANTAGED AND GET
THE LEAST AMOUNT OF SLEEP.
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM WHO
GETS THE BIGGEST BENEFIT AFTER
THE CHANGE.
THAT COHORT OF STUDENTS.
WERE ASKING THE APPROPRIATE
QUESTION ABOUT GETS THE BIGGEST
BENEFIT -- TRANSPORTATION COSTS
THE REASON WHY WE STAGGERED
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL.
THIS YEAR IS TO HELP OFFSET ANY
POTENTIAL TRANSPORTATION COSTS
THOUGH MOST OF THE DATA AND
RESEARCH SHOWS.
THERE IS AN INCREASED COST AND
SOME DATA SHOWS THAT FOR EVERY
DOLLAR SCHOOL DISTRICT INVEST
THEY GET FOUR DOLLARS
[inaudible]
IN RETURN [inaudible]
THE BILL ITSELF.
SETTING.
STANDARD.
IT SAYS NO EARLIER THAN THAT
DOESN'T MEAN DISTRICTS DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ADJUST.
AND AS POINTED OUT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILEY.
BY RESPECTING THE SCIENCE ON
MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND SETTING THAT
MINIMUM. FOR FOR EIGHT FOR
MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND A MINIMUM FOR
FOR HIGH SCHOOLS AT EIGHT THIRTY
AGAIN THOSE ARE MINIMUMS ALLOWS
DISTRICTS THAT FLEXIBILITY. TO
WORK IN CONCERT WITH THEIR
TRANSPORTATION FOLKS TO ADJUST
THEIR SCHEDULES WE'VE LEFT OUT.
THE LITTLE KIDS ON PURPOSE FOR
TWO REASONS A THEIR SCIENCE AND
BRAIN CHEMISTRY IS DIFFERENT AND
BE THAT ALSO GIVES DISTRICTS THE
FLEXIBILITY. FOR THAT THE CHAIRS
COMMENT ABOUT THE SERVING CLASS
AND ZERO APPEARED AGAIN THE
RIGHT QUESTION TO ASK ZERO
PERIOD.
IS EXEMPT FROM THIS BILL WAS
FIRST PERIOD JUST TO BE CLEAR
DON'T DON'T MISS.
BUT CHARACTERS MY STATES MOVES
ABOUT FIRST PERIOD NOT NOT ZERO
PER SERVING CLASSES DURING FIRST
PERIOD.
I'LL BE CLEAR IN A NON
NEGOTIABLE AND I WILL SUBMIT AND
COMMIT TO THE CHAIR TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE THE
CITY THE SURFING CLASS.
WORK FOR ANYBODY WANTS BY THE
WAY THIS MAY SHOCK YOU.
BUT I ACTUALLY SERVED WHEN I WAS
A KID.
I DIDN'T LOOK LIKE THIS.
BUT AND WHEN I WAS A KID I USED
TO GET IN TROUBLE BECAUSE THERE
WAS A SURFER'S BEACH.
AND OF COURSE WE ALL WOULD GO
OVER TO THE SURFERS BEACH
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE ALL THE
COOL KIDS WERE -- BUT ANYWAY
PSYCH SUBMIT TO TO TO WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT THE APPROPRIATE WAY. TO
ADDRESS.
WHETHER THAT FITS THE DEFINITION
OF A ZERO PERIOD BECAUSE IT'S
VOLUNTARY OR NOT.
YOU KNOW I'M NOT LOOKING TO MAKE
THIS BILL.
ARE JEWISH BUT I THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBBER'S -- PERCEPTION
ABOUT DISTRICT REPRESENTATIVE
SAYING OFF LINE GOD I HOPE THIS
BILL PASSES I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
MANY SUPERINTENDENTS HAVE COME
UP TO ME AND SAID.
I'VE READ ALL THE RESEARCH I'D
LOVE TO MOVE MY SCHOOL DISTRICT
BUT I DON'T WANT TO DEAL WITH.
WITH WITH.
THOSE ISSUES BECAUSE SO PLEASE
DO IT THE STAGGERED.
EXTRACURRICULAR AGAIN PERFECT
EXAMPLE THERE ARE DISTRICTS OUT
THERE THAT WANT TO MOVE.
BUT BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
ON STAGGER THEIR EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES SO ALL OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN ASKED.
ARE THE RIGHT QUESTIONS WE THINK
THE SCIENCE THE RESEARCH THE
LACK OF INCREASED COSTS WE THINK
IT'S IT JUSTIFIES.
MAKING THIS MINIMUM STANDARD
BASED ON THE RECOMMENDATION OF
THE PEDIATRICIANS ABOUT WHAT'S
IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF OUR
KIDS.
SHOULD BE THE OVERRIDING GOAL
AND AS WHAT'S BEEN SAID IF WE
SAVE ONE LIFE.
THAT'S WORTH IT.
THANK YOU SENATE ONE LIFE THAT'S
WORTH IT SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT -- MOTION IS -- DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS THERE'S BEEN A
A MOTION AND A SECOND --
MATHEMATICS AFTER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL NO
O'DONNELL NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE DEEP KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH NOT VOTING WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I THOSE THREE THE BILL AS
IS ON BECAUSE THREE VOTES YOU
HAVE ANOTHER BILL YOU'RE
PRESENTING YES I DO AND I GET TO
THAT IN AN ON CALL I APPRECIATE
IT AND THE TIME YOU GAVE US.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FILE ITEM [inaudible] SIX NINE
ONE NINE FILE NUMBER SIX FILE
ITEM OR SIX SB. SIX NINE FIVE
YOU MAY.
PROCEED WHEN READY
-- SURELY.
I HAVE ANOTHER EASY BILL.
AS CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY THANKING YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH
MY STAFF.
OVER THE THREE YEARS ON THIS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE -- I
KNOW KRISTY LOPEZ FROM MY STAFF
AND YOUR STAFF.
HAVE REALLY REALLY WORKED HARD
TO GET THIS BILL WHERE IT IS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB SIX NINE
FIVE WHICH REQUIRES A LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY TO PROVIDE A
STUDENT'S PARENT.
WITH A COPY OF THE COMPLETED
INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION PLAN OR IEP
FOR THE EIGHT MOST COMMONLY
SPOKEN LANGUAGES IN THAT
DISTRICT.
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF BEING
REQUESTED AS WELL AS REQUIRE THE
AYE HE PIECE TO BE TRANSLATED BY
A QUALIFIED TRANSLATOR.
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRE CD TO
REVISE ITS NOTICE OF PROCEDURAL
SAFEGUARDS IN ORDER TO INFORM
PARENTS OF THEIR RIGHT TO
REQUEST.
THE TRANSLATION OF DOCUMENTS
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS FOR
TRANSLATED COPY OF THE IEP BUT
DOES NOT SET A TIME LINE FOR IP
DOCUMENTS TO BE TRANSLATED --
WE'VE HEARD STORIES FROM PARENTS
THAT IT TOOK UP TO A YEAR TO
RECEIVE THE DOCUMENTS AND IT
APPEARED. TO BE TRANSLATED USING
A POPULAR SEARCH ENGINE NOT AN
ACTUAL TRANSLATOR.
THE IEP PROCESS CAN BE
OVERWHELMING AND INTIMIDATED FOR
SOMEONE FROM IT -- NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE PROCESS OF THE
TERMINOLOGY IS SPECIALLY OF THAT
PERSON'S PRIMARY LANGUAGE IS NOT
ENGLISH.
THE LACK OF HAVING A TIMELY AND
ACCURATE TRANSLATED IP DOES A
GREAT DISSERVICE TO BOTH THE
PARENTS AND THE STUDENTS THINK
ABOUT.
HOW PRECIOUS TIME IS TO THOSE
EARLY LEARNERS IF YOU DELAY
KNOWING WHAT YOUR I. E. P. IS
FOR A YEAR?
THAT'S IRREPARABLE DAMAGE TO THE
YOUNG PERSON SO THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL IS FOR PARENTS HAVE
MEANINGFUL PARTICIPATION.
IN THEIR CHILD CHILDREN'S IP
PROCESS WHICH IS REQUIRED BY LAW
AND ALSO TO PROVIDE PARENTS WITH
A TRANSLATED COPY OF THE I. R.
P. I. E. P. WITHIN THAT TIME
FRAME SO.
I HAVE ERIC HARRIS FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ FROM
COALITION OF HUMAN IMMIGRATION
RIGHTS TO SPEAK ON THE MERITS OF
SB.
SIX NINETY FIVE GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ERIC HARRIS AND I'M A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
A NONPROFIT ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVANCES AND
PROTECTS THE RIGHTS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES.
WE HAVE WORKED FOR THE LAST
THREE YEARS ON THIS BILL WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSORS OF SB SIX
NINETY FIVE A BILL THAT WOULD
HELP STUDENTS AND FAMILIES GET
TRANSLATIONS.
OF INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
ARE I. E. P.'S.
FASTER WITHIN THIRTY DAYS.
THIS IS A NECESSITY IN A STATE
AS CULTURALLY DIVERSE AS
CALIFORNIA AND WITH SO MANY
LANGUAGES SPOKEN.
THANK YOU AND I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHEN MEMBERS
KRISTA RESPONSES WITCHER LE THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS WHERE WE ARE CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST IN RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
WE'RE PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR OF
SB. SIX NINE FIVE FIVE YOU
PROCESS AS MENTIONED BY THE
SENATORS VERY INTIMIDATING FOR
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES WHOSE PRIMARY
LANGUAGE IS NOT LANGUAGE IS NOT
ENGLISH MANY TIMES FAMILIES
REPRESENT HAVE A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF DISTRESS.
DURING THIS PART OF THE IEP
PROCESS WHEN TRANSLATION IS
NEEDED. FOR EXAMPLE PARENTS FEEL
LEFT OUT OF THE CONVERSATION IF
THEIR SIDE CONVERSATIONS
HAPPENING I AND I MEDIAN -- AND
THEY FILL THE SOMETIMES THEIR
STATED.
THAT WHEN OUR STAFF HAS NOT
FULLY TRANSLATED WHAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO CONVEY AN IP PROCESS.
PARENTS BECOME MORE FRUSTRATED
WHEN DOCUMENTS ARE PROVIDER NOT
PROPERLY TRANSLATED IN FACT AS
AS MENTIONED EARLIER SOME
MEMBERS HAVE STATED THAT THEY
HAVEN'T RECEIVED DOCUMENTS.
THAT MANY TIMES BEEN TRANSLATED
BY ON MY SYSTEM SUCH AS GOOGLE
TRANSLATE NOT WHICH MAKES NO
SENSE IN THEIR OWN LANGUAGE. SIX
NINE FIVE ENSURE THAT FAMILIES
ARE ENGAGED IN IP PROCESS ARE
NOT TREATED AS SECOND CLASS
CITIZENS BY ENSURING DOCUMENTS
PROVIDED.
DURING IP PROCESS ARE PROPERLY
TRANSLATED AND GIVEN IN A TIMELY
MANNER IN DOING SO THIS BILL
WILL ASSIST IN RESTORING TRUST
BETWEEN IMMIGRANT FAMILIES ARE
ENGAGED IN THIS PROCESS.
SCHOOLS AND OVERALL IN
GOVERNMENT.
OUR STATE HAS MADE IT C<c.cyan></c>
CLEAR COMMITMENT IMMIGRANTS AND
THEIR CHILDREN OR OFTENTIMES
CITIZENS OF THE UNITED STATES
THAT THEY SHOULD BE TREATED THE
SAME AS ALL OTHER CALIFORNIANS.
AND SB SIX NINE FIVE DOES THAT
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE DRIVE A
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GEN GLORIA BEHALF WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT.
SHANNON PRIMER SPECIAL NEEDS
PARALEGAL WHO HAS TO CLIENTS
WITH THIS ISSUE I'M ALSO WITH
EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND EMPOWER
FAMILY CALIFORNIA WE ARE FROM
SUPPORT.
AND SEE WHAT OTHER ME NUMBER IS
A WRESTLING ANGLE SO MOTHER
THOSE THING IS GOING TO BE IS
NOT MY NAME IS ROSALYN I'M THE
MOTHER OF TWO KIDS WITHOUT THE
SOME.
I'M ALSO FARM CO FOUNDER OF
INTEGRATED -- INTEGRATE
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE I SEE SEE WE ARE
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA WE HOP ON
GROUPS AND ALL OF A CALIFORNIA
AND I'M HERE SUPPORTING AND THEY
IS ME. SIX NINETY FIGHT IN
SUPPORTING THE EFFORTS TO THEIR
SEATS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ME NUMBER NINETY SANCHEZ SO
ESTARá PERSON BAND ALL ASSUME.
ARE LIKE WHEN THE ITEMIZED
RECEIPT IS STILL UP FOR OUT OF
ANY SAYS HE ON A IS THE NAME
NICE ICC.
I'M SUPPORT FOR THIS HAVE
RELATED RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
HELLO MY NAME IS STORE CONTRARY
US AND I'M GRANDMOTHER TO IN A
TESTING GROUND SON I'M A RETIRED
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR IN THE
TREES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND I'M ALSO IN AND TAKEN OTHER
WHAT I REPRESENTING THE
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE ORGANIZATION.
IN STOCKTON AND SURROUNDING
AREAS I SUPPORT DISABILITY
RIGHTS.
IN THE PASSAGE OF SB
[inaudible]
SIX NINETY FIVE THANK YOU.
WHEN I START THIS ME NUMBER IS
GOOD HE SAID THIS DROUGHT THAT
HE YOUR APPLE YOU'LL -- THIS
HEAVILY TO RICE CALIFORNIA BY
NOT A LESBIAN Là AB SAKES LIVE
IT SINGLE IS VERY ACCURATE
PERCENT ON OUR LOCAL MONEY THAT
THE FATHER IS THE FRENCH CAM.
MONTH THEY GOT LATE PRO IS DR
LODI MORE THIS SO YES COLOGNE --
AND MISS BETTY IS HERE COMO
FATHER THAT THOSE YOU CLICK ON
NOTE.
VERY IMPORTANT TO US LATE.
BUT AND THEN THERE NEED THE MOST
INTENDED ONLY A BANK YOU
[inaudible] FOR WHAT.
WHEN I STARTED THIS MY NUMBER IS
MIGHTY SUCH A LOT YOU CAN GO 2%
ON LONG ISLAND AN EXISTING
FORCES SALINAS?
THEY THEY THEY GIVE A CALIFORNIA.
SHE'S REPRESENTING AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED FORCES
UNITED.
HEY YES THEY IT'S ALMOST ALMOST
A KEEP IT UP WE HAD A LITTLE IS.
A LIST OF IT IS. SIX SIX NINETY
FIVE ME NUMBER IS MARIA YELLOW
THING ONLY YOU'RE GOING
O'DONNELL.
GIVING ALL THE LIGHT THIS BILL
IN THE GROUP REPORTERS ONLY THIS.
GIVEN THE BOY IN THE LAW THIS
SERVICE SAID KNOWING THEY SINGLE
ESSAY OF A SINGLE WHEN THEY
CAN'T GO. SEVEN I'M DOING.
NOW.
WE DON'T DO THAT HERE.
WE DO HAVE FUN THOUGH.
THE NUMBER OF MONEY -- CHARM
BIGELOW BY.
SAYING GO THOSE IN THE AT THE
SOUTHEAST THE VERY SAME MOMENT
THEY SEEM COOL BUT I THINK.
WHEN THE THOUGHT OF THEM IN THE
LETTER THAT I GOT STATUS THING
WITH THOSE NEW YORK ON OF THESE
SMALL?
EVEN WALKWAY UNDERLIES SERVICE
SAID HAVEN'T THEY SINGLE NOTHING
OF MY NAME IS ANGIE RIVERA AND I
AM THE FOUNDER OF UP OIL THE
FATHERS BUT IT BOTHERS THE
SPANISH SPEAKING SUPPORT GROUP
WE'VE BEEN AROUND FOR THIRTY
YEARS.
WITH A MEMBERSHIP OF ONE HUNDRED
PEOPLE AND I ALSO WORK FOR UC
DAVIS MIND INSTITUTE AS A
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE AND WE
SERVICE PEOPLE EVERYWHERE AND I
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
ALL I MEAN I'M GONNA START
MOVING WITH A LIGHT UP FOR YOU
WHAT IT SAYS WILL NEED US.
EVEN THEN WAS A BOY YOUNG THOUGH
IS SERVICE A. C. AND THEN WITH A
SINGLE CRISIS.
ALL THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS WERE
FROM FORCES UNITED.
SIMON WHO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BE ABLE
HEALTH AGENCY OR IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SEEN -- FOR THEIR SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEN OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS
READY COMMITTEE MEMBER SINGLE
COMMENTS MANY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
THIS BILL THE MOVED AND SECONDED
MOVE BY MISS SMITH SECOND MOSTER
KALRA -- THE MOTION IS -- TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS -- YOU
MAKE CLOTHES A MAKE UP FOR MY
LAST CLOSE IN THE SHORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE
[inaudible]
JOHN.
CLOSE RIGHT THERE -- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
PREPARATIONS FOR DONALD.
BY THE DONALD I KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING DEEP KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER I DOES WORK.
THE BILL.
THE BUS FOR VOTE SO IT IS OUT.
YOUR AVAILABLE FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE SENATOR SKINNER.
FILE ITEM THREE YOU MAY.
PROCEED WHEN READY.
WHERE SHE THEIR SHOES?
IT'S SP.
FOUR ONE NINE AND WHILE I'M
THREE YEAH
[inaudible]
THE CENTER.
OKAY.
AND AFTER -- CENTER SKINNER WILL
HAVE CENTER HERTZBERG.
YOU MAY PROCEED [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
THE YEAH [inaudible]
YOUR WORKING IN THE SENATE BILL
AND THE YEAH.
YEAH BUT I DON'T.
HEARINGS [inaudible]
YEAH -- IF YOU [inaudible]
CATEGORY.
IT IS NO.
WE HAVE HAD THREE GRADUATING.
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS AND
LEGISLATURE ABOUT -- THE
REQUESTED BY.
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACTION.
MOON FAR MORE.
FAR MORE IMPORTER OR MALICE OR
WHO KNOWS WHAT THEN IS THERE.
AND IT'S AN UNFORTUNATE THING.
BUT IT REALLY IMPACTS THE
ABILITY OF THOSE KIDS TO SUCCEED
IN SCHOOL.
AND THEY HAPPEN TO BE FAR MORE
SUBJECTED AND ALL OF OUR DATA
SHOW SAID TO A CATEGORY OF
SUSPENSIONS CALLED WILLFUL
DEFIANCE WHICH YOU CAN LOOK AT
AS SORT OF AN ATTITUDINAL THING.
AND THAT THERE SUSPENDED FOR
THAT -- AND WHEN YOU'RE
SUSPENDED FROM SCHOOL.
THAT ISN'T A GREAT RECIPE FOR
SUCCESS IN SCHOOL YOU'RE IN
EFFECT IT'S COMMUNICATES THAT
HEY WE DON'T WANTYOU HERE SO
WHY SHOULD YOU WANT TO BE WHERE
YOU'RE NOT WANTED.
AND ADDITIONALLY YOUR LOSS OF
THAT SCHOOL ING GET YOU BEHIND.
IN YOUR CLASSES.
SO WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO ADDRESS
THIS FOR SOME TIME AND LAST YEAR
IN THE BUDGET.
THERE WAS MADE PERMANENT THE
ELIMINATION OF THIS SINGLE
CATEGORY OF OF SUSPENSIONS
CALLED WILLFUL DEFIANCE IN
GRADES.
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH THIRD.
NOW THERE HAVE BEEN MANY MANY --
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
EVEN OUR SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
ASSOCIATION SAID AS WANTED TO GO
FURTHER SO THE BILL YOU HAVE
TODAY IS A BILL THAT WOULD
[inaudible]
MAKE.
THERE WOULD ELIMINATE WILLFUL
STIFF FINES SUSPENSIONS THROUGH
GRADE FIVE SO ADDING TO WHAT WE
ALREADY DID.
BY ADDING GRADES FOUR AND FIVE
TO THAT PERMANENT THIRD
[inaudible]
AND THEN.
ELIMINATING WILL FOLDS DEFINED
SUSPENSIONS.
THROUGH FOR GRADE SIX AND EIGHT
SIX SEVEN EIGHT SIX THREE WITH A
FIVE YEAR SUNSET SORTS NOT
PERMANENT.
IT HAS A FIVE YEAR SUNSET -- NOW
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS ISSUE
STILL ADDRESS HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS BUT I APPRECIATE THE
ARGUMENTS.
AND NINE MEAN ARGUMENTS BUT IAPPRECIATE THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THAT HIGH SCHOOL IS DIFFERENT.
AND THAT -- THE THE BEHAVIOR IN
HIGH SCHOOLS DIFFERENT
EVERYTHING ABOUT THE WHAT
OPTIONS THE HIGH SCHOOL TEACHERS
AND SUCH HAVE -- SO I RESPECT
VERY MUCH THE WAY THE BILL'S
CONSTRUCTED.
AND THE AMENDMENTS WE'VE TAKEN.
BUT I HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
OUR CONVERSATION OVER TIME
AROUND.
ALSO TRYING TO LOOK AT CREATING
THE MOST [inaudible]
OPTIMAL CIRCUMSTANCES IN OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM FOR
STUDENTS TO SUCCEED AND WITH
THAT I WOULD LIKE MY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT TO TESTIFY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN I
THINK I IS AND I'M A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD RISING SENIOR AT
GARFIELD HIGH SCHOOL.
I'M HERE WITH INNER CITY
STRUGGLE THE BROTHERS THEMSELVES
COALITION AN ALLEY COUNTY AND
THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
NINETEEN BECAUSE AS A STUDENT I
FEEL THE SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT HAS
BECOME SAFER SINCE WE ENDED
WILLFUL DEFINES AS A MEANS OF
SUSPENSION.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE
BROTHERS SON SELVES COALITION
AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS AND HOW
THEY PASSED THE SCHOOL CLIMB A
BILL OF RIGHTS IN LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. ONE OF
THE THINGS THE SCHOOL CLIMB A
BILL OF RIGHTS DID WAS AND
SUSPENSIONS IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOR DEFIANCE.
I WAS A FIFTH GRADER AT THE TIME.
BECAUSE OF THAT STUDENTS WERE NO
LONGER PULLED OUT OF CLASS AND
SUSPENDED FOR MINOR INFRACTIONS
LIKE WEARING A HAT HAVING YOUR
BIRDS IN CHEWING GUM.
AND THEY WEREN'T FORCED TO MISS
VALUABLE CLASS TIME.
BECAUSE OF THIS I FELT SAFE
REGISTERED.
AS BEFORE NINETEEN ALLOW
STUDENTS TO STAYING CLASS
FURTHER.
STAY IN CLASS AND FURTHER THEIR
EDUCATION RATHER THAN BE BOTH BE
PULLED OUT AND FALL BEHIND ON
CLASS WORK.
AND A STUDENTS EDUCATION IS
SUPPOSED TO BE PROTECTED.
NOT USE AS A THREAT AGAINST THEM.
BECAUSE OF AS BEFORE NINETEEN
STUDENTS WHO ARE DEEMED HARD TO
DEAL WITH.
WILL NOT WILL NO LONGER BE
THROWN OUT OF CLASS OR SUSPENDED
BECAUSE IT'S CONVENIENT.
RATHER RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PRACTICES WILL BE IN IMPLEMENTED.
RELATIONSHIPS CONVERSATIONS
TRUSTS AND DIALOGUE WILL BE PUT
IN THE PLACE OF PUNISHMENTS.
STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO EXPLAIN
TO THE TO THE TEACHERS ARE
SITUATIONS AND TEACHERS WOULD BE
ABLE TO GAIN A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE STUDENTS
AND FIND A WAY TO HELP THEM.
I STATED EARLIER LA YOU IS THE
HAS ALREADY ENDED WILLFUL
DEFINES AS A MEANS OF SUSPENSION.
AND IT HAS SERVED AS A POSITIVE
EDUCATIONAL CATALYST.
AS A STUDENT I HAVE SEEN OF
ASKED CHANGING CLASSROOMS.
AND HAS BEEN BETTER.
BETTER FOR EVERYONE.
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES ARE NO LONGER
BEING HEAVILY SUSPENDED AS THEY
WERE BEFORE.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO SAY THAT ALL
STUDENTS IN THE STATE DESERVE
THIS PROTECTION NOT JUST YOUNG
ADULTS [inaudible]
YOUNG.
ALTHOUGH S. BEFORE NINETEEN DOES
NOT PROTECT HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
WE HOPE THE LEGISLATOR IT WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US. TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE.
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE GROUPS
LIKE STUDENTS OF COLOR.
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
AND LGBT STUDENTS.
I HOPE TO SEE THIS IMPLEMENTED
ACROSS THE NATION.
ONE BUT BEFORE THAT HAPPENS.
HAS THAT BEEN HERE.
SO I CAME HERE TO IMPLORE YOU
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
PLEASE SUPPORT STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANOTHER WHAT
ANOTHER WITNESS YES GOOD
AFTERNOON.
MR CHEN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
YVONNE CARRY ON WITH ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS.
ACCESS PROUD TO SUPPORT AS
BEFORE ONE NINE BECAUSE WILL FOR
DEFIANCE POLICIES CONTINUE TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND BECAUSE
THERE ARE MORE EFFECTIVE
APPROACHES FOR DEALING WITH REAL
AND PERCEIVED IT DEFINES.
THE MAJORITY OF ACCESS
MEMBERSHIP IS MADE UP OF
PRINCIPALS AND VICE PRINCIPALS.
WHOSE JOB INCLUDES -- HANDLING
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS AND
MANAGING CAMPUS SCHOOL CLIMATE.
IN THIS SEGMENT OF OUR
MEMBERSHIP REPORTS HAVING
SUCCESS IMPLEMENTING ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES THAT STRENGTH AND
STUDENT CONNECTEDNESS.
REDUCE NEGATIVE BEHAVIORS AND
IMPROVE ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE.
THESE INCLUDE PROGRAMS THAT
DEVELOP MEANING MEANINGFUL
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN STAFF AND
STUDENTS.
ONES THAT RECOGNIZE AND REWARD
POSITIVE BEHAVIORS -- PROGRAMS
THAT ADDRESS UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
STRATEGIES THAT PROMOTE PEER TO
PEER ACCOUNTABILITY IN CONFLICT
RESOLUTION.
BUT EVEN AS MORE AND MORE
SCHOOLS ARE IMPLEMENTING THE
STRATEGIES AND REDUCING THEIR
USE OF SUSPENSIONS ACTS A
BELIEVES THAT WILL FOR DEFIANCE
MUST BE ELIMINATED.
ACCESS CANNOT SUPPORT A POLICY
THAT OVERWHELMINGLY AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS.
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS MAKE
UP JUST OVER 5% OF THE STATE'S
STUDENT POPULATION GET REPRESENT
NEARLY 16% OF THOSE WERE
SUSPENDED FOR WILLFUL DEFIANCE.
BLACK STUDENTS ARE THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO BE SUSPENDED FOR
WORLD WILL FOR THE FINANCE THAN
THEIR WHITE PEERS.
AND RESEARCH CLEARLY SHOWS THE
RISK INVOLVED WITH SUSPENDING
YOU'VE.
KIDS WHO ARE SUSPENDED ARE FIVE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO DROP OUT OF
SCHOOL.
AND ELEVEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
BECOME INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
STUDENTS ARE SAFEST AND BEST
SERVED WHEN AT SCHOOL FOR THESE
REASONS ACCESS SUPPORTS AS
BEFORE ONE NINE A RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JUST COME UP TO MY CURRENT STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY PLEASE.
ACTUALLY.
WHEN WE HOPE TO STAY IN SUPPORT
BUT WE MIGHT HAVE TO PULL ARE CO
SPONSORS HAVE SINCE IT WAS
DROPPED -- TWO K. THROUGH EIGHT
INSTEAD OF K. THROUGH.
TWELVE I'M HERE FOR THREE YOUNG
PEOPLE CHRIS CARTER ON A LOPEZ
AND JEREMY PEROT WHO WERE ALL
KILLED DURING SCHOOL HOURS --
LEAVING HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AT
ITS MOST DANGEROUS AGE GROUP
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
MARCO PART WITH POLICY LINK IN
THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR IN STRONG SUPPORT LAUSD
BAND THE SUSPENSIONS FOR OUR
GRADES FIVE YEARS AGO AND NOW
THEY HAVE BETTER OUTCOMES.
YOU CAN'T GET TO THE END USER
STUDENT SUCCESS WITHOUT HAVE
BUILT SENTENCE IN SCHOOL THANK
YOU YES I SUPPORT THE THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS KEVIN TRAUMA BEHALF
THE COMPTON UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF BLACK SCHOOL
EDUCATORS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
THERE CLINICS ON BEHALF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SAID DEBORAH BROWN ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS COPPING SO I'M WITH --
MERCED AND SACRAMENTO BLACK
PARALLEL SCHOOL BOARD AND MARIE
IN SUPPORT.
CAN'T BE SURE FOR ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THREE
SANDERSON THE ARE CAN YOU SEE P.
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON OSKAR LARA WITH
INNER CITY STRUGGLING WERE
SUPPORT.
CALL IMPACT -- WITH LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
THEY RETURNED WITH THE BUT THE
SUN CELLS COALITION SIX BLACK
STUDENTS ARE SIX POINT 75% ARE.
MORE LIKELY THANK YOU TO BE.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION.
MILLER LIKE A SUB IN USERS
COALITION IN SUPPORT PROTECTING
ALL STUDENTS K. THROUGH TWELVE
FROM THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE.
MAY RODRIGUEZ AND EDUCATION
TRUST WESTERN STRONG SUPPORT.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE HAD A
SUPPORT IF UNLESS AMENDED ON
THIS BILL OR SUPPORT IF AMENDED
ON THE BILL.
BECAUSE OUR CONCERN IS WITH THE
HIGH SCHOOL PIECE AND THE FACT
THAT WE STILL DON'T HAVE.
MULTIPLE SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT WE
DON'T HAVE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
WE DON'T HAVE TRAINING FOR ALL
TEACHERS ESPECIALLY IN THE HIGH
SCHOOL ROUND WE DO GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE GIVEN AND WE MAY HAVE TO
HAVE A SUPPORT POSITION.
URBAN YOUTH JUST COALITION
HERE'S A SPORT I IN CARE OF
FRAUD CASE K. THROUGH TWELVE
THANK YOU.
SIGNAL FOR THEIR OPPOSITION WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE --
THANK YOU CENTER -- I'M SORRY I
APOLOGIZE ANGELES HAND PUBLIC
COUNCIL I'M SORRY ANGELA TURNER
PUBLIC COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OKAY
THANK YOU I APOLOGIZE -- AT
OPPOSITION YEAH I DO HAVE THE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL I
APOLOGIZE.
SEEING OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE HERE AND
I'LL JUST COMMENT THANK YOU FOR
THE BILL SENATOR I KNOW MY
CONCERN IS REALLY ALL
SUSPENSIONS.
AND HAVING BEEN IN A HIGH SCHOOL
FOR MANY YEARS -- I WOULD NOT
I'M NOT ONE THAT WOULD SAY YOU
SHOULD NEVER SUSPEND THERE ARE
CERTAIN INSTANCES WORLD REALLY
FOR SAFETY ISSUES ALONE
SOMETIMES YOU MUST SUSPEND BUT
YOU SHOULD NEVER SUSPENDED FOR
WEARING A HAT.
AND I CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING
MORE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE THAN
SUSPENDING A STUDENT BECAUSE ARE
LATE FOR SCHOOL.
SO IF THOSE THINGS ARE GOING ON
I DON'T THINK YOU REALLY HAVE A
LEGAL OR NEED A LOT OF PROBLEM
YOU'RE PROBABLY HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PROBLEM -- AND
I'M THE KIND OF TEACHER YOU KNOW
I I DIDN'T KEEP REFERRALS MY
DESK I WAS IN THAT WHAT KIND OF
GUY I CAN'T TELL YOU IF EITHER
YEARS.
YEARS WENT BY WHEN I DIDN'T EVEN
WRITE -- ONE BECAUSE YOU USE
YOUR PEOPLE SKILLS RIGHT THE
RELEASE OF THEIR KIDS THEIR
GROWING.
AND YOU GOTTA BE FLEXIBLE
SOMETIMES YOU KNOW FLEXIBILITY
INFLEXIBLE -- SO I APPRECIATE
THAT AGAIN MY REAL CONCERN IS
ALL SUSPENSIONS AND I KNOW THIS
YEAR'S.
TOO SO I'M AND I DON'T TAKE THAT
AWAY FROM YOU -- SO I SO I
APPRECIATE THE BILL AND WILL
HAVE FURTHER CONVERSATIONS
CLEARLY -- WITH THAT I THINK
DOCTOR WEBER WANTED TO COME
RIGHT I WANT -- TO ARE CLEARLY
THINK -- SENATE FOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD IN AND THIS IS
BEEN SOMETHING ON THE AGENDA FOR
AT LEAST A LONG AS I'VE BEEN
HERE -- AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT WE HAVE TO AMENDED TO LEAVE
UP THE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
BECAUSE THAT REALLY IS ONE OF
THE MAJOR CHALLENGES THAT'S
THERE THAN WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT -- I GUESS IT WAS
PROBABLY A COUPLE YEARS AGO I
WAS ASKED INVITED TO GO TO
WASHINGTON NEW YORK.
TO PARTICIPATE IN A CONVERSATION
CONCERNING SUSPENSIONS AND
EXPULSIONS.
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING
I WAS INVITED SO I WENT AND I
EXPECTED TO YOU KNOW TO LEARN A
LOT FROM FOLKS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IS THE WHAT THEY WERE
DOING.
AND A LOT OF THEM WITH THEIR BUT
WHAT SHOCKED ME MOST WAS I GOT
THE IN WHO WAS LEADING THE
CONVERSATION AS A THOR HE'S IN
THE ROOM WAS AT DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
IN CALIFORNIA -- AND THEY HAD
ALL THE RESEARCH AND ALL THE
DATA IN ALL THE INFORMATION IT
JUST KIND OF BLEW ME AWAY
BECAUSE YOU I DON'T SEE THEM
PRESENTING THAT DATE AND THAT
INFORMATION AND DRIVING IF
YOU'RE CALIFORNIA.
AND SO I WAS KIND OF SHOCKED
THAT THEY WERE THERE AND AND AND
AND THAT THEY HAVE BEEN DOING
THIS WORK AND AND WERE REALLY
STRONG SUPPORT IS AGAINST US THE
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS.
AND AND YOU KNOW THEY WERE
INFORMING OTHER STATES ABOUT
THIS ISSUE WHEN WE WOULD NOT
LEADING IN PRACTICE SO I JUST
FOUND IT EXTREMELY.
INTERESTING FOR ME TO COME THERE
AND REALIZING THAT I WAS WALKING
IN TO BE ON THE TEAM OF EXPERTS --
WHEN I THOUGHT I'D BE HEARING
FROM OUR OWN DEPARTMENT -- OR
HEARING FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS
AND WE HEARD FROM SOME OF THEM
AS TO WHAT NEED TO MOVE FORWARD
AND SO I EVEN TODAY I STILL
DON'T SEE THEM HERE LEADING THE
CHARGE.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
LOTS OF WORK ON A LOTS OF
RESEARCH ON AND I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT -- THAT WE NEED
TO TAKE THE LEAD ON IT'S IT'S I
MEAN I DON'T WITH THIS WHEN I
WAS IN SCHOOL WERE TWENTY SOME
YEARS AGO ABOUT THE OVER
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS OF
KIDS IN THE OUTCOMES AND AND ALL
THOSE THINGS THAT WAS SO UNFAIR
AND SOMEONE JUST.
IN DEALING WITH THE CHILDREN OF
THAT WOULD BEARD WHO WAS GETTING
SUSPENDED AND EXPELLED AND EVEN
WHEN WE WOULD ELIMINATED THEY'D
BE THE KIDS SITTING IN THE
HALLWAY RATHER THAN IN THE
CLASSROOM FOR INSTRUCTION.
SO WE HAVE TO DO A BETTER JOB
AND WE KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO DO I
MEAN I WAS LISTENING TO ALL OF
OUR EXPERTS TALK ABOUT AND I
THOUGHT TO MYSELF.
YOU KNOW IT ARE WE GIVING THIS
INFORMATION FOR TRAINING IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND ARE WE HELPING FOLKS
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE DOING
AND HOW THEY'RE DOING AND IT
JUST SEEMS. TO BE SUCH A
TREMENDOUS DISCONNECT HERE IN
THE STATE BETWEEN WHAT OUR
DEPARTMENT WAS DOING THIS ABOUT
FOUR YEARS A SO WHAT I'VE
DEPARTMENT KNEW AND WAS DOING IN
RECOMMENDING.
AND YET WHAT WE WERE DOING IN
TERMS OF PRACTICE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO -- I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT'S
AN ONGOING CHALLENGE -- WE NEED
TO GET TO THE POINT WHERE WE
REALLY LOUD ALLOW THE RESEARCH
IN THE WORK THAT WE DO WITH THE
STATE DEPARTMENT. TO DRIVE THE
ACTIVITIES IN THE SUPPORT FOR AT
OUR SCHOOLS IN THIS AREA BECAUSE
IT IS EIGHT EIGHT IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND ALL THE DATA IS CLEAR
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN KIDS WHEN
THEY'RE SUSPENDED AND EXPELLED.
EARLY IN LIFE PARTICULARLY --
WAS STILL SUSPENDING KIDS IN
KINDERGARTEN AND ALL THAT STUFF
THE DEADLY MAKE A WHOLE LOT OF
SENSE -- BUT I I I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK AND YOU EFFORTS AND I
THINK WE HAVE TO JUST CONTINUE
TO PUSH A LITTLE BIT HARDER.
MOVE THE BILL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
AND I SAID ONE HIGHLIGHT THAT
THE SUSPENSION RATE IS NOW PART
OF THE DASHBOARD.
YES REALLY YES TELLS A LOT RIGHT
AND REALLY MAKES DISTRICTS PAY
ATTENTION OR NOT JUST.
FOR THE FINAL FOR ALL ALL
REASONS -- SO WITH THAT I SEE NO
FOR THE COMING FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MISTER KALRA THANK YOU MISTER
HAND UP SHAPER SHOULD -- AND AND
HAVE I OBVIOUSLY HAD THE STEP UP
FOR ANOTHER QUICK MEETINGS DID
GET A CHANCE TO HEAR SOME OF THE
DIALOGUE BUT I CAN GUESS AS TO
WHERE SOME OF IT WAS AND I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT.
ANY EFFORT -- FOR US TO REDUCE --
THE USE OF WILL FOR DEFIANCE --
IN A MANNER THAT IS EXCLUDING --
STUDENTS FROM TO SPANISH CASES
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHO THE TARGET
IS OFTENTIMES TO DATE AT LEAST
OF WILLFUL DEFIANCE AND AND I I
OR FRANKLY.
I I SECOND OTHER COMMENTS A AS I
WAS WALKING HEARING FROM DOCTOR
WEBER -- ABOUT THE EXCLUSION OF
THAT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE'RE SEEING A MUCH
OF THE DISPARITY THAT THERE'S
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES TO ENGAGE
OUR STUDENTS -- OF THAT BOARD
EVER REASON -- A TEACHER MAY
BELIEVE IS NOT ENGAGING IN A WAY
THAT'S HELPFUL TO THEM.
I THINK THAT -- HAVING.
I I THINK THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY EVEN AS THIS BILL --
GOES FORWARD TO BETTER DEFINE.
BOTH OF WILL FOR THE FINANCES
THE SUBJECT SUBJECTIVITY OF IT
THAT IS SUCH THE IS SO MUCH AN
ISSUE WE HAVE OTHER.
BILL'S GOING FORWARD IN THIS
BODY REGARDING AN IMPLICIT BIAS
FOR EXAMPLE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES.
AND THE EMPRESS OF BY IS THAT
EXIST AMONGST ALL OF US AS PART
OF THE OF THE DATA THAT OCCURS
REGARDING WILLFUL DEFIANCE
SUSPENSIONS EXPULSIONS WHAT HAVE
YOU.
THAT -- IS A DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS -- PARTICULARLY -- THE
YOUNG MEN OF COLOR BUT CERTAINLY
YOUNG STUDENTS OF COLOR.
AND THE SUSPENSION SHOULD BE
MADE VERY CLEARLY IS AN OPTIONAL
LAST RESORT -- WHEN ADDRESSING
BOTH OF DEFIANCE RATHER RATHER
THAN REMOVING IT I UNDERSTAND
CERTAINLY THE THE CHAIR AND
OTHERS CONCERNS OF HAVING ALL
THE TOOLS AVAILABLE BECAUSE
TEACHING IS NOT EASY?
AND I THINK WE ALL AGREE WITH
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
TEACHERS TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO TEACH ALL OTHER STUDENTS AND
AND THAT THERE'S ISSUES WITH ANY
GIVEN STUDENT THAT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED I THINK THAT WE SHOULD.
BUT IT TO THAT POINT THERE
SHOULD BE AS MANY TOOLS AS
POSSIBLE RATHER THAN THE
SUSPENSION ROUTE -- PROVOKE OR
SHORT OF THE SUSPENSION ROUTE
AND SOME HOLE I HOPE THAT.
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD AND
AS THIS ISSUE CONTINUES TO BE
DEBATED -- IN THE IN THE YEARS
AHEAD THAT WE HAVE A RECOGNITION
THAT WE SHOULD USE ALL TO WHAT
THE THE ALL THE TOOLS AVAILABLE
SHOULD BE USED TO LIFT UP OUR
STUDENTS AND TO PROVIDE.
CERTAINLY A SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR
EVERYONE BUT REALLY DAHLE AND
GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE HEALING ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS.
OF ANY ISSUES THAT THEY MAY BE
GOING THROUGH THAT'S KEEPING
THEM FROM HAVING A FULL
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE AND
EXCELLING.
US WITHOUT A A WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL ALTHOUGH I DO THINK -- THAT --
BUT I I WOULD SUPPORT IT PRIOR
TO AMENDMENTS -- AND AND THINK
THERE'S STILL AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO CONTINUE TO DISCUSS THIS
IN TERMS OF SOME OF THE CHANGES
THAT THAT.
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THE CHILD
ON THE STUDENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A SINGLE FOR THE
COMMENT FROM THE COMMITTEE THERE
HAS BEEN IN MOTION THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED -- I KNOW I
CAN GET THERE.
ARE YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
ASKED FOR YOUR I'VE LOST MAKE
SURE YOU CLOSE SO CLOSE WELL.
WE HAVE A CLOSE FAST DRIVE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOU CAN TAKE MORE TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR.
NOW WITH THAT -- PUT THEM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO DEEP [inaudible]
NO KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY EYES SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER I'D.
THOSE FIVE ALSO IT IS OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
MISTER ROB GET UP HERE BEFORE
SOMEONE COMES IN.
AND BEFORE YOU.
START MISTER ROTH I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT BEFORE YOU KNOW WE IN
THIS COMMITTEE USUALLY PEOPLE
WALK OUT AS A LOT OF NOISE.
THIS IS PROBABLY OUR LAST RIGHT
NOW.
SCHEDULED HEARING OF THE OF THE
YEAR THERE MAY BE ANOTHER WHO
KNOWS BUT MAYBE NOT I JUST WANT
TO THANK THAT THE COMMITTEE
STAFF TONYA [inaudible]
AND CHELSEA.
AND MARGUERITE.
AND DEBBIE AND SOPHIA -- LEANS
AND HELPS THE COMMITTEE
SOMETIMES TOO AND OF COURSE JOHN
C. WHO REALLY RUNS THE SHOW THE
COMMITTEE SECRETARY SO I JUST
WANT.
TO HIGHLIGHT THEM FOR THEIR WORK --
THIS YEAR AND AND AND THEY'RE
ALWAYS GREAT THEY'RE GREAT TO
WORK WITH.
SO WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM US SENATOR ROBB WE'RE GONNA
GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE WHICH IS SB. FIVE EIGHTY
SIX YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF WELL
FIRST I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT
PRESENTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND TO ECHO YOUR
EARLIER COMMENTS I WANT TO THANK
YOUR STAFF FOR THEIR EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE THIS BILL.
THE BILL IS -- RESPONSE TO
CONCERNS RAISED AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING THAT -- WE HELD ON
CAREER TECHNOLOGY THE NEW
ECONOMY.
AT THAT PARTICULAR HEARING -- I
HEARD FROM A VARIETY OF
STAKEHOLDERS CONCERNED OVER THE
GROWING NEED FOR SKILLED LABOR
TO MEET LOCAL INDUSTRY
EMPLOYMENT GROWTH.
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO SIMPLY
ADDRESS THE CONCERN BY PROVIDING
A FORUM FOR THE LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENTBOARD'S. TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS THEY
DEVELOP THEIR COLLEGE AND CAREER
ACCESS PATHWAYS IT'S SIMPLY.
AN INFORMATIONAL FLOW BILL.
THANK YOU I'M SUPPORT ANY ANY
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL -- ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SEEN
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE -- ANY ANY
COMMENTS READY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEN A CONSUMMATE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
MISMAS MOVES -- SECONDED BY
MISTER KALRA -- IN THE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
AND YOU MAY CLOSE.
LIKE THIS FOR A VOTE THANK
MISTER THANK YOU SENATOR --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR O'DONNELL HI
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I'D.
BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS.
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON WE
HAVE ONE MORE MISTER HERTZBERG.
IF YOU'RE LISTENING AND YOU'RE
IN HIS OFFICE BETTER GET IN HERE.
WHEN WE TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WILL WAITING FOR
SENATOR HERTZBERG TO COME DOWN
HERE?
THE CONTENT CALEDON MOVED AND
SECONDED.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM ONE SB ONE SEVENTY FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM FOR SB
FIVE EIGHTY TWO THE MOTION IS
THE PASTOR.
FILE ITEM EIGHT S. J. R. EIGHT
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
O'DONNELL IN THE MOVED AND
SECONDED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY I'D DEEP.
DEEP I KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY.
MCCARTY EYES SMITH SMITH I WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
ARE THAT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS A MOTIVE IS OUT.
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR SENATOR
HERTZBERG.
HE'S ON HIS WAY.
HOW MUCH TIME SHOULD BE GIVEN
COMMITTEE?
WHAT ABOUT SECONDS?
HOW MY ALONG [inaudible]
CALLS.
GOOD JOB WHAT WE LIVE THE CALL
MAKING.
PLEASE CUT PLEASE OF KOREA.
FILE ITEM TO SB.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT THE MOTION
WAS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING NO DEEP.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I BILLS FOR VOTED IS OUT
[inaudible]
VETERANS.
YEP BUT WILL MOVE TO ADD ON'S
NOW.
FILE ITEM SIX SB SIX NINETY FIVE
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'D [inaudible]
DEEP.
DEEP NO.
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I THE BILL HAS FIVE
PHONES IT IS OUT.
THE LAST DAM.
YEAH IT IT IT DOES -- MISTER
DEEPENED AND WELCOME TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MISTER DAVE.
WHAT DID YOU DO TO GET HERE?
DON'T SAY OR DON'T SAY SORRY.
OKAY WITH THAT WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
FILE ITEM SEVEN IS SB. SEVEN
FORTY THREE MISTER HEARD CENTER
HERTZBERG YOU MAY.
PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU SHERMAN I AM -- HERE
TODAY IT HAS TAKEN THE TIME TO
INTRODUCE THIS MEASURE. TO
CORRECTIVE ANOMALY.
IN THE DESIGN BUILD METHOD AS IT
RELATES TO THE CONSTRUCTION OF
SCHOOLS.
THERE'S BEEN SOME CONFUSION IN
CASE OF TOWARD A ABOUT WHETHER
WHEN YOU HAVE A DESIGN BUILD
CONTRACT.
AND THE END SEQUEL UC BOTH ON
TWO SEPARATE PASS WITH THE
CONFLICT WITH EACH OTHER.
AND SO IF SO IF IF THE SCHOOL
BOARD APPROVES THE DESIGN BUILD
PROCESS.
IS THAT CONSIDERED APPROVAL OR
NOT.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO
CLARIFY.
AS WE DEAL WITH ALL THESE GREAT
ISSUES OF WILD FIRES AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND ALL THE GREAT ISSUES
OF THE DAY.
OFTEN THE MECHANICS OF
GOVERNMENT ARE INFORMED BY
THINGS IT APPEARS SMALL.
BUT IMPACT IN A SIGNIFICANT WAY
THE OPERATION OF GOVERNMENT THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE LITTLE THINGS
THAT WE'RE DOING. TO CORRECT
THAT -- WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
AS PART OF THIS JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE AWARDING OF A
CONTRACT.
APPROVING DESIGN BUILD IT --
PROJECT -- IF FOR TWO PURPOSES
DOES NOT WORK CAN CONTRADICTION
WITH WITH C. CUT.
AND WITH THIS.
I HAVE MY WITNESS TALK AND
FURTHER EXPLAINED.
THE PROBLEM WITH HERSELF.
THANK YOU TERRY MEMBERS -- MY
NAME IS OLGA SHILOH WITH LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT --
WE ARE PLEASED TO BE THE SPONSOR
OF SB SEVEN FORTY THREE WHICH
CLARIFIES THAT DESIGN BUILD
PROJECT DELIVERY METHOD.
DESIGNED BILL PROJECT DELIVERY
METHOD PROVIDES MANY
EFFICIENCIES TO SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS INCLUDING
COST EFFECTIVE USE OF FUNDS AND
EX BUT I TO PROJECT COMPLETION.
SINCE DESIGN BILLS TOUCHES WERE
ORIGINALLY MADE OPERATIVE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO LA UNIFIED HAS
AWARDED TWENTY THREE CONTRACTS
OF A CUMULATIVE TOTAL OF NEARLY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
CURRENTLY WE ARE WORKING ON A
DESIGN BUILD CONTRACTS TO BE
AWARDED TOTALING OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
LA UNIFIED PURSUIT DESIGN BUILD
PROJECTS WHEN A DETERMINATION IS
MADE THAT THE CONTRACT
CONTRACTING METHOD WILL REDUCE.
PROJECT COST EXPEDITED PROJECT
SCHEDULE INTO PROVIDE FEATURES
NOT ACHIEVABLE THROUGH THE
TRADITIONAL DESIGN BED BUILD --
CONTRACTING METHODS.
WE HAVE FOUND THAT A PROJECT
SCHEDULED IS REDUCED BY FORTY
SIX MONTHS ON AVERAGE.
THE X. BUT I'D NATURE OF DESIGN
BUILD WHILE TIMELY AND COST
EFFECTIVE SOMETIMES RYAN RUNS
INTO TIMING ISSUES WHEN IT COMES
TO THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT REVIEW.
IN ORDER TO EVALUATE EVALUATE
WHETHER PROPOSED PROJECT IS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE C<c.cyan> IT IS</c>
NECESSARY TO HAVE CERTAIN
INFORMATION KNOWN.
ABOUT IT IN THAT CAN ONLY BE
REVEALED THROUGH THE DESIGN
DEVELOPMENT STAGE THIS OCCURS
AFTER A CONTRACT IS AWARDED.
DUE TO DEATH OFTENTIMES BOARDS
OF EDUCATION APPROVED THESE
CONTRACTS BEFORE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW IS COMPLETE.
RECENTLY THE STATE DISTRICT
AWARDED A DESIGN BUILD CONTRACT
TO MODERNIZE WAS ABOUT HIGH
SCHOOL WHICH WAS ARGUED BY SOME
THAT THE ACTION MEANT THE LA
UNIFIED HAD ALREADY APPROVED IN
THE PROJECT.
AND COMMITTED ITSELF TO AN
IRREVERSIBLE INDEFINITE COURSE
OF ACTION WITHOUT CONDUCTING
APPROPRIATE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
UNDER SEEK WHAT SB SEVEN FORTY
THREE WHILE PROTECTING TO SEE
WHAT PROCESS CLARIFIES.
THE LA UNIFIED RETAINS THE RIGHT
TO TERMINATE A DESIGN BUILD
CONTRACT.
BEFORE THE PROJECT IS SUBMITTED
TO THE DIVISION OF STATE
ARCHITECT MODIFIED THE DESIGN
AND IN CORPORATE MITIGATION
MEASURES IDENTIFIED IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW DOCUMENT
FOR THE PROJECT.
SB SEVEN FORTY THREE HARMONIZES
THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS
WITH THE RECOGNIZE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS A FORTY TWO LA UNIFIED --
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE PROUD
TO SPONSOR SB SEVEN FORTY THREE
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
IPHONE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JEREMY SMITH HERE BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ARE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE MOVE I MISS SMITH BY SEX
SECOND I WAS MCCARTY -- YOU MAY
CLOSE THAT THE MOTION IS
[inaudible]
DO PASS -- YOU MAKE CLOSE.
THAT'S RESPECTFULLY AS FROM
ABOUT THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU
AND WHAT WE'RE ALL HERE AND
WE'RE ALL LISTENING I HAVE TO
TAKE ONE MOMENT HERE AND THANK
MISTER BECKER AS WELL I THINK
EVERYBODY BUT YOU.
QUE AND YOU'RE THE NICEST GUY
HERE.
GEN.
YOUR POSITIONS ARE OFTEN CRAZY
BUT OU KNOW A VERY NICE GUY SO --
THANK YOU FOR BEING YOU.
<c.red>N DOING WHAT YOU DO WE NEED A</c>
LOYAL OPPOSITION THERE'S TOO
MANY ALL ASPECTS THAT ARE AT
LEAST MOST OF IT.
AND THANK GOD BOB FOR HIS.
INVALUABLE GUIDANCE AS WELL AS
HARD WORK THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY UP PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR O'DONNELL.
HI O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I'D KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
THE EYES SMITH SMITH I WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I'D.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN ROADS IT IS
OUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU MEMBERS PUSH IT MUCH.
THANK YOU.
SO WHAT WE CAN ADJOURNMENT.
WITH THAT.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.
THE MONEY FACTOR [inaudible]
OKAY --